Hey guys, it's really rainy out there today, who's getting wet? Who's getting droopy and droopy in their drawers? Who's getting real chilly under the collar? And who's getting ready to be heated up because of all that mess? Let's get hot on Smartless! Oh boy, guys, it is cold here in Los Angeles, you know what I could have used last night? What's that Jason? An extra blanket, maybe even a Sherpa blanket, huh?
大家好，外面今天雨下得真大，谁淋湿了？谁的裤兜都湿嗒嗒、软塌塌的？谁缩着脖子觉得直发冷？又有哪些人因为这一团糟而准备火冒三丈？让我们在Smartless节目里火热起来吧！天哪，伙计们，洛杉矶今天可真冷，你们知道我昨晚需要什么吗？什么呀，杰森？一条额外的毛毯，甚至可能是一条夏尔巴绒毯，对吧？
You know where you get one, Jay? Where? Where? Well, if you go to, I don't know if my coordinates are correct here, but if you go to www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless, what's that? That's our Merch Madness store. Can I get sweats there? Do they sell Sherpa blankets in there?
你知道在哪能买到吗，杰伊？在哪？在哪？好吧，如果你去，我不知道这里的坐标对不对，但如果你去 www.wondrishop.com 斜杠 Smartless，那是什么？那是我们的“疯狂周边”商店。我能在那里买到运动裤吗？里面卖夏尔巴绒毯吗？
Can I get t-shirts? Can I get t-shirts? Yeah, of course! What about warm socks? Yeah, of course! That'd be great for the cold weather now. Do you like joggers? Do you like phone cases?
我能买到T恤吗？我能买到T恤吗？可以，当然可以！那保暖袜子呢？可以，当然可以！这对于现在的寒冷天气来说太棒了。你喜欢慢跑裤吗？你喜欢手机壳吗？
What do you look like the joggers? Do you like popsockets? I don't even know what those are. I'm going to buy three t-shirts and a Sherpa blanket right now at www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless. You did it again. You only did two Ws. www.
你觉得慢跑裤怎么样？你喜欢气囊支架吗？我甚至不知道那是什么。我马上要去 www.wondrishop.com 斜杠 Smartless 买三件T恤和一条夏尔巴绒毯。你又来了。你只打了两个W。www.
It's going to be three Ws. So hard for me. And this is the World Wide Web. This is it. Yes. www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless go. We got all this new Smartless merchandise. It's so good.
会有三个W的。对我来说太难了。这就是万维网。就是这个。是的。www.wondrishop.com 斜杠 Smartless，走起。我们有所有这些新的 Smartless 周边商品。太棒了。
The hats are amazing. Listen, for storytellers like us who are creating content, no, but just hear me out. As a content-creating storyteller, we got it, we got it, we got it. You can come and load up, speaking of loads. Wait really quick. I just want to talk about this because it's been in the news for several weeks and I'm obsessed with the UFOs that they're shooting down. And today I was watching the news and it's funny how they're kind of skirting around
帽子太绝了。听着，对于像我们这样创作内容的讲故事的人来说，不对，听我把话说完。作为内容创作者、讲故事的人，我们懂了，我们懂了，我们懂了。你可以来大买特买，说到买……等一下，很快。我只是想聊聊这个，因为它已经在新闻里播了好几个星期了，我对他们击落的不明飞行物简直着迷。今天我在看新闻，有趣的是他们怎么在绕着弯子说
it like, like it has to be alien stuff, right? It can't be. No. Sean probably not. No, but it can't, it can't just be whether Scotty can stop painting his face. It's not, there's not going to be a big, a big painting in his face. Take the tin foil out of the windows. Yeah.
这事，就好像，好像这肯定是外星人的东西，对吧？不可能。不。肖恩，大概不是。不，但这不可能，不可能只是斯科特能不能停止画脸吧。这不是，他的脸上不会有一个大大的、大大的彩绘。把窗户上的锡纸拿掉吧。对。
No, I think it's just, it's a different kind of balloon. They're flying a different kind of surveillance device now. I think so. They said it's not surveillance or anything. No. And somebody pointed out that if aliens sent these craft over here from wherever the hell, they wouldn't be easily downed by our dumb weapons, you never know, you never know, right? They may be dumb too.
不，我认为这只是，这是一种不同类型的气球。他们现在在飞一种不同类型的监视设备。我也这么觉得。他们说这不是监视或者别的什么。不。而且有人指出，如果外星人把这些飞行器从见鬼的什么地方派到这里来，它们不会轻易就被我们这些愚蠢的武器给击落，你永远不知道，你永远不知道，对吧？它们可能也很蠢。
They might be dumb too. But anyway, you know who isn't Tom? Our guest today has quite the stellar and sparkly reputation. Oh, I thought this was Willie's guess. This is yours. This is mine. Yeah. Sean's get there.
它们可能也很蠢。但不管怎样，你知道谁不是汤姆吗？我们今天的嘉宾有着相当 stellar（闪耀/极佳）和 sparkly（闪闪发光）的声誉。哦，我以为这是威利请的嘉宾。这是你的。这是我的。没错。肖恩的嘉宾在那儿。
It is right there. This is so fun. Really? Yeah. I can't believe we get to talk to this fella. I might get a little starstruck not just because he's celebrated here in the United States, guys, but he's very much celebrated internationally too. Really?
就在那儿。这太有趣了。真的吗？对。真不敢相信我们能和这家伙对话。我可能会有点追星成功的小激动，不仅因为他在美国备受赞誉，伙计们，而且他在国际上也享有盛誉。真的吗？
By the way, he's not even American. Many fans may not realize he was once cast as a James Dean type and a rebel without a cause type adaptation, which I'm obsessed with. I'm the first thing I'm going to talk to him about. And we're on the street is there's no one nicer in Hollywood. His first name in Hawaiian means cool breeze over the mountains. Guys, it's the legendary Count of Reeves. No.
顺便说一句，他甚至都不是美国人。许多粉丝可能没有意识到，他曾被当作詹姆斯·迪恩式的演员，出演过无因的反叛者类型的改编作品，我对此着迷不已。我跟他聊的第一件事就是这个。坊间传闻好莱坞没人比他更好了。他在夏威夷语里的名字意思是“山吹来的凉风”。伙计们，这就是传奇的基努·里维斯。不。
He's over the mountains. Really? Wait. I didn't know that. This just picked my mood up a lot. Where are you? Are you in a hotel room right now? I am.
他吹过山峦。真的吗？等等。我不知道这个。这让我的心情一下子好了很多。你在哪？你现在在酒店房间里吗？是的。
I'm at the Four Seasons in West Hollywood. We're not paying for that. We're not paying for that. No. No, I'm doing some John Wick chapter four press for a film. I can't wait to talk about it. You put this into your junket schedule. That is a very nice thing to do because that's a hall doing that stuff.
我在西好莱坞的四季酒店。我们可不付这钱。我们可不付这钱。不。不，我在为一个电影做《疾速追杀4》的宣传。我已经等不及要聊聊这个了。你把这塞进你的宣传行程里了。这是一件非常好的事情，因为做那些事简直就是受罪。
Yes. Come on. You're tired and you've been doing lots of press and then you got to talk to us idiots. No. This is so cool. We're going to up our game. We're going to up our game because you've got a couple of roundtables after this or you got.
对啊。拜托。你很累，一直在做各种宣传，然后还得跟我们这群白痴聊天。不。这太酷了。我们要提高水平。我们要提高水平，因为你这之后还有好几场圆桌采访，或者你还有。
No, I'm good, man. I'm good. I'm good. Dude, great to meet you, man. Yeah. Cheers. I've been such a huge fan for so long. It's so nice to meet you.
不，我挺好的，老兄。我挺好的。我挺好的。老兄，很高兴认识你，真的。干杯。我当了你这么久的超级粉丝。很高兴认识你。
Yeah. This is so cool for us. So Keanu, let me ask you something because we as a Canadian, we always claim you as a Canadian. Is it? What's your Canadian status? Really? Where would you put it?
对。这对我们来说太酷了。基努，那我问你个问题，因为作为加拿大人，我们总是把你当成加拿大人。是吗？你的加拿大身份是怎么样的？真的吗？你会把它放在哪里？
But wait. Let me just jump in with that. Beirut. Born and Beirut. Born and Beirut. Canada. Yeah. Chinese, Hawaiian, European.
但等等。让我插一句。贝鲁特。出生在贝鲁特。出生在贝鲁特。加拿大。对。中国、夏威夷、欧洲。
Do you want him to answer it? I mean, you can tell me. I mean, I can just look up his Wikipedia. He's trying to show off that he did research. Yeah. The story of my past is obviously the story of my mother. And so she ran away from home when she was like 15. And she ended up going to Beirut, Lebanon, and as you do, she was born in England.
你想让他回答吗？我是说，你可以告诉我。我是说，我可以直接查他的维基百科。他是在显摆自己做了功课。对。我过往的故事显然是我母亲的故事。所以她大概15岁时从家里跑了出来。她最后去了黎巴嫩贝鲁特，就像你做的那样，她出生在英国。
And she met a guy, and they had a kid, and that's me. And then it's a long story, but my, it does, there's a bit of adventure in their journey. And then my father had a stepfather who was Canadian, and then there's a bunch of stuff that happened, but long story short, me and my sister and my mom ended up moving into a house in Canada. And so that's how I became Canadian when I was like seven or seven years old. Did you, so did you go to, you went to school, a lot of school in Canada in Toronto? Well, I went to, I was raised in Toronto, and I went to, I went to Jesse Ketchum.
然后她遇到一个人，他们生了个孩子，那就是我。然后这是一个很长的故事，但是我的，确实，他们的旅程中有一点冒险色彩。然后我父亲有一个继父是加拿大人，接着发生了一堆事情，但长话短说，我和我姐姐还有我妈妈最后搬到了加拿大的一座房子里。所以我大约七岁的时候就成了加拿大人。你，所以你去了，你在加拿大上过学，在多伦多上过很多学？嗯，我在，我在多伦多长大的，我去了，我去了杰西·凯彻姆学校。
Did you really? Yeah. Do you know it? Yeah. Crazy Will. Of course. Oh, look how excited. Now he's out.
真的吗？对。你知道吗？对。疯狂的威尔。当然。哦，看他多激动。现在他暴露了。
I graduated from Leeside High School. Leeside. Yeah. Yeah. I am, the two high schools that were, our grade school fed, what the fuck were they called? Northern. And.
我从利赛德高中毕业。利赛德。对。对。我是，我们初中直升的高中，他妈的叫什么来着？北方。还有。
Northern? Yeah. North Toronto. I went to NT, I went to North Toronto for one year. You did? Yeah. I went to North Toronto for one year. And I'm trying to remember the other Jarvis.
北方？对。北多伦多。我在NT上过学，我在北多伦多上过一年。你真的去过？对。我在北多伦多上过一年。我在努力想另一个贾维斯。
And Jarvis, so my sisters went to Jarvis and my nephew is graduating from North Toronto this year. Well, congratulations. Thank you. And congratulations to you. Is that right? Hey. Yeah.
还有贾维斯，我姐姐们去了贾维斯，我侄子今年从北多伦多毕业。嗯，恭喜。谢谢。也恭喜你。是这样吗？嘿。对。
So are you a Maple Leafs fan as well? I was. I was. I played a lot of ice hockey as a kid, and so yeah, I played a lot of hockey. I played a lot of hockey. No more. You don't, you don't, you don't play in one of these Hollywood leagues or teams. No, I never got into the Hollywood leagues.
所以你也是枫叶队的粉丝咯？我曾经是。我曾经是。我小时候打了很多冰球，所以是的，我打了很多冰球。我打了很多冰球。现在不打了。你不会，不会，不会在好莱坞的这些联赛或球队里打球吧？不，我从来没加入过好莱坞的联赛。
I played a lot. When I, when I got here, I played, I mean, I played in some leagues in Los Angeles and I discovered that you could play pickup hockey basically every day. Yeah. Really? And so I played a lot of that and I'm, I'm a goalie. So is Will. Oh my God, Will.
我打过很多。当我，当我来到这里时，我打过，我的意思是，我在洛杉矶的一些联赛里打过球，我发现你基本上每天都能打野球。是吗？真的吗？所以我打了很多，而且我，我是一名守门员。威尔也是。哦天哪，威尔。
Take it easy. So was I. I played Goal at North Toronto at the, at the rink there at North Toronto, right? Nice rink. Yeah. Great rink. Good ice. By the way, you should be noted, I got an email today from somebody I know here in
别激动。我也是。我在北多伦多当过守门员，就在北多伦多的那个冰场，对吧？不错的冰场。对。很棒的冰场。冰面很好。顺便说一句，应该提一下，我今天收到一封邮件，来自我在
LA saying, Hey, do you want to go and play, pick up the, they call it pickup hockey. Of course we call it chinny, but do you want to go and play some pickup hockey in this league? And I said, man, I just wrote back like two hours ago. I was like, I'm too old, man. I care. No, but what, what, what if, what if they're old too and then everyone takes it easy in the corners?
洛杉矶认识的一个人，他说：“嘿，你想不想去打冰球？”他们管这叫打野球（pickup hockey）。当然我们管这叫 chinny，但你想不想去这个联赛打场野球？我说，老兄，我大概两个小时前才刚回信。我说：“老兄，我太老了，我才不呢。”不，但是什么，万一，万一他们也很老，然后大家都收着打，在底角不怎么对抗呢？
Everyone's old. Yeah. But you know, and then you end up, you can, you fall or you take a bad hit and then you're like, what the hell am I doing? What am I doing out here? What am I doing? Yeah. I went to, I went to four different high schools in Toronto.
大家都老了。对。但你知道的，然后结果就是，你会摔倒或者挨记狠撞，然后你会想：“我到底在干什么？我在这儿干什么呢？我在干什么？”对。我上过多伦多四所不同的高中。
So I went to North Toronto for two years and then I went to a performing arts high school. Got kicked out of that. Sure. Really? Then I went to, I went to Dilla Sal on Avenue road, dude, dude, that Dilla Sal is on Farnham and I grew up on Farnham. I grew up, I grew up a hundred yards from Dilla Sal. What?
所以我去了北多伦多高中两年，然后我去了一所表演艺术高中。被开除了。真的？真的吗？然后我去了，我去了法纳姆大道上的德拉萨，老兄，老兄，那个德拉萨在法纳姆街，而我在法纳姆长大。我长大的地方，我离德拉萨只有一百码远。什么？
You guys probably walked by each other a million times. You're both the same age. I'll be you. I'll be you. I'm 52. I'm 58. So okay. Yeah.
你们俩可能擦肩而过上百万次了。你们俩同龄。我敢打赌。我敢打赌。我52岁。我58岁。所以好吧。对。
So you were probably, you were probably walking along the street there when I was like a punk kid, you know, that's amazing. Yeah. Yeah. That's why. And then, and then there's a Hawaii in there. No. I'm sorry.
所以你可能，你可能在那里的大街上走过，而我当时就像个朋克小孩，你知道，这太惊人了。对。对。这就是为什么。然后，然后里面还有一个夏威夷人。不。不好意思。
Yeah. It's my father's Hawaiian. So he, he, he grew up in Hawaii and then he got into some trouble. And so he ended up going to be living on too. And that's where he and my mom met. Where did your mom go before Beirut? Where was she? She was born in England and she went to Paris.
对。我父亲是夏威夷人。所以他，他，他在夏威夷长大，然后惹上了一些麻烦。所以他最后去了贝鲁特生活。那就是他和我的母亲相遇的地方。你母亲在去贝鲁特之前去过哪儿？她在哪里？她出生在英国，然后她去了巴黎。
Wow. She was interested in fashion and design. And so I think she worked at a fashion house, I tell you. So you guys just moved around constantly? Yeah. Yeah. Even in Toronto, there's a lot of, I got a lot of gypsy in my story. Yeah.
哇。她对时尚和设计感兴趣。所以我想她在一家时装屋工作，我跟你讲。所以你们一直在到处搬家？对。对。甚至在多伦多，有很多，我的经历里有很多吉普赛色彩。对。
You got a lot of good stuff cursing through you. Yeah. Is your, now is your, is your sister in the arts? She's in the equestrian arts. Okay. Yeah. She was in the arts. Yeah.
你身上流淌着很多精彩的特质。对。那你的，现在你的，你姐姐从事艺术行业吗？她从事马术艺术。好吧。对。她以前从事艺术。对。
So she was into horses, training horses, riding, could do anything, everything on a horse. And that was her deal. And my, so my husband, Scotty, he is an army brat. He's moved, he moved 17 times before he was like, you know, 20 or something like that. Wow. And, but moving around made him want to desire to be stable in one place and never move again. Are you like that? Or did that upbringing make you feel like, are you drawn to like different experiences
所以她喜欢马、驯马、骑马，能在马身上做任何事、一切事。那就是她的追求。而我的，所以我丈夫斯科特，他是一个军人家庭的孩子。他搬过，他在大概20岁或类似年纪之前搬过17次家。哇。而且，但频繁搬家让他渴望在一个地方安定下来，再也不搬家了。你是那样的人吗？还是那种成长经历让你觉得，你总是被不同的体验所吸引
all the time? Hmm. I think both. Oh, okay. If you can be both. I mean, I think, you can. I mean, I love traveling. I love new experiences.
吗？嗯。我觉得两者都是。哦，好吧。如果你能两者兼得的话。我的意思是，我觉得，你可以。我的意思是，我喜欢旅行。我喜欢新的体验。
I mean, I think, you know, with the arts that we're in, you know, if it works out, you get a chance to travel around and, you know, meet folks and, and so I love that experience, but it's also important. I mean, I love, I love a good couch, a little home. Yeah. Who doesn't? Yeah. Good God.
我的意思是，我觉得，你知道，凭我们从事的艺术行业，你知道，如果顺利的话，你就有机会四处旅行，你知道，结识各色人等，所以我也很喜欢这种体验，但同时也很重要。我的意思是，我喜欢，我喜欢一张舒适的沙发，一个温馨的小家。对。谁不喜欢呢？对。天哪。
And, and then, of course, then the itch starts. Yeah. Exactly. And then it's a fever and then you're distracted and then. How long, how long are you good on the couch without, without any work or without any, any work that you know is coming up? Cause that's right. You just want to measure it.
然后，当然，接着那种痒痒的感觉就开始了。对。没错。然后那就像是一种狂热，然后你就分心了，然后。你在沙发上呆多久不会觉得腻，在没有任何工作、也没有任何你知道即将到来的工作的情况下？因为没错。你只是想衡量一下。
You just want to measure it. Yeah. It's like, if you know works coming up, like you have a start date on something, I can sit on my couch for six months. But if I don't know anything's coming, I, I'm about two weeks. Oh yeah. Unemployed. I call it the working on working.
你只是想衡量一下。对。这就好比，如果你知道有工作要来，比如你手里有个项目的开机日期，我可以在沙发上坐六个月。但如果我不知道有什么要来，我大概两周就待不住了。哦，对。失业状态。我管这叫“为工作做准备”。
Yeah. I mean, it really depends on what the, what the journey you had before you're unemployed. Right. Right. You know, like if you, you know, if you have like, if you, if you've been working and it's been really intense for five or six months, you know, you come out of that, you know, you might not be thinking about being unemployed and working on working for a day or two, but two months.
我的意思是，这真的取决于你失业前经历的那段旅程是什么样的。对吧。没错。你知道，就像如果你，你知道，如果你一直在工作，而且过去五六个月非常紧张，你知道，你从那种状态里出来，你知道，你可能一两天内都不会去想失业或者为工作做准备的事情，但两个月。
Yeah. And if you don't do, you, you do jobs that they, they shoot a lot of nights. There's a lot of action. Yeah. There's weapons. Yeah. But I mean like, you don't have like easy days on your movies, no rom-coms for you. No, I like a good rom-com.
对。而且如果你不做，你拍的工作通常有很多夜戏。有很多动作戏。对。有武器。对。但我的意思是，你的电影里没有轻松的日子，没有浪漫喜剧适合你。不，我挺喜欢好的浪漫喜剧的。
I got to work with Ali Wong. I did a couple of days on an Ali Wong show. She's funny. I've done, she's amazing. And, but no, I've, I've had the fortune to do some pretty, some pretty epic shooting. Like, I mean, working on Matrix two and three was 22 months. Wow. My God.
我有幸和黄阿丽（Ali Wong）合作过。我在黄阿丽的一个项目里客串了几天。她很搞笑。我拍过，她太棒了。但是不，我有幸拍过一些相当、相当史诗级的打戏。比如，你知道，拍《黑客帝国2和3》花了22个月。哇。天哪。
And all the John Wick's are like, that, that ain't no phone in. Yeah. No, there's no phones. I remember, I remember seeing that first John Wick. Well, first of all, I mean, for now that we're, you've opened, you, you open up. Yeah. I had a bunch of before that. So, well, okay.
而且所有的《疾速追杀》都那种，那可不是随便糊弄的。对。不，没有糊弄。我记得，我记得看第一部《疾速追杀》。好吧，首先，我的意思是，既然我们已经，你敞开了心扉。对。我之前还拍过一堆呢。所以，好吧。
Well, I'm, everybody's got a bunch. Jesus. Why are you arguing with me? I want to talk to him. He's tired. He's not going to deal with that one. And, and so I remember what being in New York, 1998 when Matrix came out, I want to say, and I know cause I have a weird thing with this and was, I couldn't have been more blown away.
好吧，每个人都拍过一堆。天哪。你为什么非要跟我争？我想跟他聊聊。他很累了。他才懒得搭理那一茬呢。然后，所以我记得1998年在纽约的时候，《黑客帝国》上映了，我想是的，我之所以记得是因为我对这方面有种奇怪的执念，我当时简直被彻底震撼了。
I had no preconceived notion because we weren't inundated at that time, all the time with the phones and stuff of leading up to stuff. So you could kind of go into a movie clean and just for what it was. Fuck man. That was such a game changer for me, that movie. Did you know why you were filming it with the effects and all of the stuff that it was a game changer? Um, I mean, you never know while you're making something, but yeah, I knew with the Wachowskis,
我没有任何先入为主的观念，因为当时我们没有被铺天盖地的手机和各种宣传搞得应接不暇。所以你可以带着一张白纸走进电影院，单纯地去感受它原本的样子。操，老兄。那部电影对我的改变太大了。你当时在拍的时候，带着那些特效和所有这些东西，你知道它会改变游戏规则吗？呃，我的意思是，你永远不会在创作过程中就知道，但是，是的，我知道沃卓斯基姐弟，
the directors, I knew their vision was extraordinary. I knew the script was extraordinary and the cast and then once it got all put together. I mean, I think of that film as a perfect film. Yeah. It's amazing. And it is like, for me too, watching that film because I hadn't seen him with the visual effects and all of that, just like, yeah. Yeah, that's great.
也就是导演，我知道他们的愿景是非凡的。我知道剧本是非凡的，演员阵容也是，一旦所有这些结合在一起。我的意思是，我认为那部电影是一部完美的电影。对。太棒了。而且就像，对我来说也是，看那部电影因为我以前没见过带有视觉特效的那些东西，就觉得，太棒了。对，太棒了。
I remember, Keanu, my oldest son is 14 and I remember just within the last couple of years, the moment of like, when I was like, we're going to watch The Matrix, man. And he's like, we're just going to, we're going to watch that because I wanted him to have the experience that I had. But you know, you, but you've always been a re in the greatest sense of the word and I don't have a better word than this, but a real director snob, like in the way that like you, you don't work in Keanu Reeves vehicles, you work in director vehicles. It seems like to me like you really appreciate someone who's got a real plan, a real vision
基努，我记得我大儿子14岁的时候，我记得就在过去几年里的某个时刻，当时我想：“我们要看《黑客帝国》，老兄。”然后他说：“我们就要，我们就要看那个，”因为我想让他拥有我曾经有过的体验。但是你知道，你，但你一直以来都是一个——用最好的词来形容，我找不到比这更好的词了——一个真正的“导演控”，就好像你，你不是在“基努·里维斯个人专属片”里工作，你是在“导演专属片”里工作。在我看来，你真的很欣赏那些有真正的计划、真正的愿景的人，
and you kind of work to service that as opposed to, yeah, I want to be the star and let's just find out any director that'll do. Is that, is that? Yeah, I mean, I, that's kind of you to say. I have, obviously, as you guys know, I mean, you want a director with a vision and I've had the chance to work with some directors who have been able to realize their vision in such extraordinary ways. And so to be on those sets, to be working with those artists is the best, man.
而你有点像是在为之服务，而不是说，我想当明星，随便找个导演就行。是这样吗？是吗？对，我的意思是，你这么说真是太客气了。我有，就像你们知道的那样，显然，你想要一个有愿景的导演，我有幸跟一些能够以如此非凡的方式实现他们愿景的导演合作过。所以能身处那些片场，能跟那些艺术家们合作，感觉太棒了，老兄。
You know, it seems to me that you have the choices that you have seemed to make all the way through a very long career. You have done so much different stuff. You know, certain people, you can see them, they get sort of into a theme thematically throughout their career. You can see this sort of through line. You've done stuff. You have just zigged and zagged and consistently done different stuff and maybe that's, I don't
在我看来，你职业生涯这么长以来所做出的选择一直都非常多元。你拍过各种各样不同的东西。你知道，有些人，你能看出他们，他们的职业生涯在某种主题上有一以贯之的东西。你能看出这种清晰的脉络。而你拍的东西。你一直在不断尝试、不断转换，始终在拍完全不同的东西，也许那是，我不知道，
know, maybe now I'm going to draw the line back to like your upbringing sort of moving around a lot. Like you like new experience, new stuff. You've done period stuff. You've done the action stuff. I'm thinking of speed with Sandy and or, you know, and, and, and then they can't pigeonhole you. It's an adventure.
也许现在我要把它归结为你的成长经历，那种经常搬家的事情。就像你喜欢新的体验，新的东西。你拍过古装片。你拍过动作片。我想起了和桑德拉一起演的《生死时速》，或者，你知道，然后他们无法把你类型化。这是一场冒险。
My own private Idaho. Dude, dude, it's fucking. Now it's first of all, Bill and Ted's. Yeah. Excellent adventure. I mean, that was, that was a game changer. Those quotable movies. I mean, I was a teenager.
《我自己的爱达荷》。老兄，老兄，那太特么了。首先是《比尔和泰德历险记》。对。好极了的历险记。我的意思是，那是个转折点。那些台词可以被到处引用。我的意思是，我当时是个青少年。
I was 18 or something. When I came out, we were fucking dying. We watched it a million times. But yeah. So you start and you do all these different things and you, it seems like you have like a thirst for that. It kind of goes into like taking jobs for the right reasons. Right.
我当时18岁左右。当它上映时，我们特么笑得死去活来。我们看了无数遍。但是，对。所以你出道并做了所有这些不同的事情，并且，你似乎对那种东西有着一种渴望。这有点像是为了正确的理由接工作。对吧。
Like, is that something that are you constantly being like, yeah, I want to do something that I haven't thought of or that's scary or that's, yeah, for sure. I mean, growing up is, you know, I always wanted to do as many different things as I could. You know, that's the hope. Right. And I find that, you know, oftentimes lead roles have certain expectations on them and whether in any genre, you know, and there's also times we're working in independent or being, you know, in supporting roles, you get to kind of do some interesting kind of nooks
就像，这是不是那种你一直在告诉自己：“是的，我想做一些我没想过的事情，或者有点吓人的事情，或者”？是的，肯定的。我的意思是，在成长过程中，你知道，我总是想尽可能多地尝试各种不同的事情。你知道，这就是愿望。对吧。我发现，通常情况下，主角往往承载着某些特定的期望，无论在哪个类型片里，你知道，而且也有时候，当我们参演独立电影或者，你知道，担任配角时，你就可以去尝试一些有趣的小角落和缝隙，
and grannies and have different voices, different tones and tell stories in different ways. So that, if you have the fortune, you know, if you have the opportunity to do a studio film or an independent film or something like that, then it's the cinema, you know, getting a chance to play and again, just tell different stories and different roles and try and do that. By the way, I don't know if anybody ever brings this up, but Dracula is one of my favorite all the time. I think Dracula, I mean, I don't know, I got kicked in the teeth and maybe deservedly
发出不同的声音，采用不同的基调，用不同的方式讲故事。所以，如果你有幸，你知道，如果你有机会拍一部制片厂电影或独立电影或类似的东西，那就是电影艺术，你知道，有机会去表演，再次强调，就是讲述不同的故事，扮演不同的角色并努力去实现它。顺便说一句，我不知道有没有人提起过，但《吸血鬼惊情四百年》是我历来最喜欢的电影之一。我觉得《吸血鬼惊情四百年》，我的意思是，我不知道，我的英国口音挨了不少骂，也许我也罪有应得，
so for my English accent, but they may, anyway. No, one of my favorites. But I think, but my English accent aside, I think that's a wonderful film. Incredible. I think Francis Ford Coppola made a work of art that was maybe a little ahead of its time. Yeah, it was amazing. I mean, the performance, Gary Oldman.
不管怎样。不，这是我的最爱之一。但我觉得，抛开我的英国口音不谈，我觉得那是一部精彩绝伦的电影。难以置信。我认为弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉创作了一部可能有点超前于时代的艺术杰作。对，太棒了。我的意思是，那个表演，加里·奥德曼。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Do you remind your team constantly to sort of find really interesting things as opposed to super lucrative things or star vehicles or things like that, or can you take responsibility for that? Because it just seems like everything you do is always interesting and it's never down the middle.
对，对，对。太惊艳了。太惊艳了。你是不是经常提醒你的团队去寻找真正有趣的东西，而不是那些超级赚钱的东西、明星专属片或者类似的东西，还是说你可以为之负责？因为感觉你做的每一件事总是那么有趣，而且从来都不是中规中矩的平庸之作。
Well, that's very kind of you to say. It's true, man. It's true. I bet you get a lot of offers to do things that would be a lot easier, a lot more predictable, a lot safer, a lot more lucrative, perhaps. And so has it been the same team forever and they just kind of know what makes you tick? Yeah, that's the representation story has been pretty consistent with the people I've worked with over the years, but that's changed over the years as well.
嗯，你这么说真是太客气了。真的，老兄。真的。我敢说你一定接到了很多片约，那些片约要容易得多、预测得多、安全得多，也许也赚钱得多。所以这么多年来一直是同一支团队，他们比较了解你的行事风格吗？对，这些年来我合作的经纪团队一直相当稳定，但这些年也有所改变。
Yeah. And at least for me personally, it's always been kind of what I was talking about, like how can we have a variety? What's the filmmaker? Where's it being made? And again, what's the script? What's the story? Yeah.
对。至少对我个人而言，一直都是我刚才说的那种感觉，比如我们怎么能保持多样性？导演是谁？在哪里拍摄？还有再次强调，剧本是什么？故事是什么？对。
What's the role? Right. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. All right, now listen, visit topgolf.com slash smartlist to book a bay and come play around. Again, that's topgolf.com slash smartlist.
角色是什么？对。我们马上回来。我们马上回来。我们马上回来。我们马上回来。好了，现在听着，访问 topgolf.com 斜杠 smartlist 预订球道，来玩上一场。再说一遍，那是 topgolf.com 斜杠 smartlist。
Our big thanks to Zip Recruiter for their support. Now, listen, I have not yet had to use Zip Recruiter because the only business I've got is this smartlist business. And we're so darn well staffed over here, but let me tell you something. Anybody steps out of line over here. I know how to get to Zip Recruiter. Are you guys listening? Not you, the listener, the people that make this show tick.
非常感谢 Zip Recruiter 的支持。现在，听着，我目前还不需要使用 Zip Recruiter，因为我唯一的业务就是这个 smartlist 业务。而且我们这里的员工已经多得不得了了，但我得告诉你一件事。这里有谁敢不守规矩。我知道怎么联系 Zip Recruiter。你们在听吗？不是你们，听众朋友们，是那些让这个节目运转起来的人。
I just want to make sure they know that I've got easy access to Zip Recruiter and I can go out there. I can start a brand new hiring line right now because Zip Recruiter just makes it that easy. So mind it. All right, now I'm back to you, listener. Whether you're starting a new business or growing one, if you want it to be successful, you need the most talented people on your team.
我只是想确保他们知道我能轻而易举地联系到 Zip Recruiter，我可以行动起来。我现在就可以开启一条全新的招聘热线，因为 Zip Recruiter 就是能把事情变得这么简单。所以都给我放老实点。好了，现在我回到你们身边，听众朋友们。无论你是在创业还是在拓展业务，如果你想获得成功，你的团队里就需要最有才华的人。
That's where Zip Recruiter comes in right now. You can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter's most powerful matching technology finds highly qualified candidates for a wide range of roles. Got your eye on one or two people who'd be perfect for your job? Zip Recruiter lets you send them personal invite so that they're more likely to apply. Zip Recruiter also offers attention grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility, like remote, training provided, urgent and more to really help your job stand out.
这就是 Zip Recruiter 发挥作用的地方。现在你可以在 ZipRecruiter.com 斜杠 smartlist 免费试用。Zip Recruiter 最强大的匹配技术可以为各种各样的岗位找到高度合格的候选人。看中了一两个非常适合你工作的合适人选？Zip Recruiter 允许你向他们发送个人邀请函，这样他们就更有可能申请。Zip Recruiter 还提供引人注目的标签，突显工作灵活性，例如远程、提供培训、紧急等等，真正帮助你的工作脱颖而出。
Let Zip Recruiter fill all your roles with the right candidates. Four out of five employees who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free. This here comes. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S.
让 Zip Recruiter 为你用合适的候选人填补所有职位空缺。在 Zip Recruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能找到优质候选人。亲自去体验一下吧。访问这个专属网址，免费试用 Zip Recruiter。网址来了。ZipRecruiter.com 斜杠 smartlist。再说一遍，那是 ZipRecruiter.com 斜杠 S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S。
Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. And I'm just kidding. I'm not looking to hire anybody. We're all one big happy family. But if I did have to, it would be real easy. Guys, we're just goofing. We are brought to you in part by Game Time. Now, I was a little stressed out trying to buy tickets a couple months back.
Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。我开玩笑呢。我可不是想招什么人。我们大家都是相亲相爱的一家人。但如果我非得招人的话，那可真是轻而易举。伙计们，我们只是在开玩笑。本节目部分由 Game Time 赞助播出。几个月前，我在买票的时候压力其实有点大。
And, you know, without mentioning the other folks in this space, it just, it was something, it was complicated. And I got stressed. I was afraid I was going to buy on the wrong night. And the prices, it's just, anyway, Game Time seems to make it real easy. It takes a stress out of it. So listen, buying tickets to your favorite events shouldn't be stressful. Game Time is the fast and easy way to buy tickets for all the sports, music, comedy,
而且，你知道的，就不提这个领域的其他人了，总之它就是，挺复杂的。我压力山大。我害怕自己会买错日子的票。而且价格，反正，Game Time 似乎把这变得非常简单。它消除了压力。所以听着，购买你最喜欢的活动的门票不应该是有压力的。Game Time 是购买你附近的各种体育、音乐、喜剧、
and the theater near you. With killer deals on last minute tickets and their best price guarantee, you can stop stressing over the tickets and start getting hyped for the fun you'll have. This sounds perfect for me. Now, I've got, Sean and I happen to be real, real fond of classical music. We don't make fun of us. We just, we like it. We don't know anyone else that does.
和戏剧门票的快捷且简单的方式。通过超值的最后一分钟门票优惠和他们的最低价格保证，你可以停止为门票感到压力，开始为即将到来的快乐而兴奋起来。这听起来太适合我了。现在，我和肖恩恰巧都非常、非常喜欢古典音乐。别取笑我们。我们只是，我们就是喜欢。我们不认识其他人也这样。
So we go with one another. So I'm going to surprise him with some classical music tickets coming up over here at the Hollywood Bowl. So Game Time is going to make it all happen for me. And I'm going to report back to you how incredible that experience was. I'm very, very excited. All right. Now, listen, Game Time is the place for last minute ticket deals. Forget planning months in advance.
所以我们总是结伴同行。所以我要在好莱坞露天剧场给他一个惊喜，送他一些即将上演的古典音乐门票。所以 Game Time 将为我实现这一切。而且我会向你们汇报那次体验有多么不可思议。我非常、非常兴奋。好了。现在，听着，Game Time 是购买最后一分钟门票优惠的好地方。忘掉提前几个月做计划吧。
Game Time has deals on tickets right up to the day of the event. Get exclusive flash deals on tickets for football, basketball, baseball, concerts, comedy, theater, and more. The Game Time guarantee means you'll always get the best price. If you find tickets in the same section and row for less, Game Time is going to credit you 110% of the difference. That's called a guarantee gang. Snag the tickets without the stress with Game Time. Download the Game Time app, create an account, and use code SMARTLESS for $20 off your first purchase.
Game Time 提供直到活动当天都有的门票优惠。获取针对橄榄球、篮球、棒球、音乐会、喜剧、戏剧等的独家限时闪购门票。Game Time 的保证意味着你将永远获得最低价格。如果你在同一区域和排找到了更便宜的门票，Game Time 将退还给你 110% 的差价。这就是所谓的保证，各位。使用 Game Time 轻松抢票，毫无压力。下载 Game Time 应用，创建一个账户，并使用代码 SMARTLESS，即可在你的第一笔订单中享受 20 美元优惠。
Terms apply. Again, create an account and redeem code SMARTLESS for $20 off. Download Game Time today. Last minute tickets. Lowest price. Guaranteed. And now, back to the show. First of all, where'd you get the bug to do it?
条款适用。再说一遍，创建一个账户并兑换代码 SMARTLESS 立减 20 美元。立即下载 Game Time。最后一分钟门票。最低价格。有保证。现在，回到节目中。首先，你当初是怎么萌生这个想法的？
Why are we artists? The Unlicked Cubs. Yeah, exactly. Because when you're in Toronto, like, when people like you that just transcend, you know, whatever, we just said it a million times how incredible your career is. Do you, is it something that finds you or you find it and why? I kind of grew up in a show biz background. My mother was a costume designer.
为什么我们要当艺术家？没断奶的小熊。对，绝对是的。因为当你在多伦多时，就像，当像你这样超越了，你知道，不管怎样的人出现时，我们刚才已经说了上百万遍你的职业生涯是多么不可思议。你觉得，这是什么东西找到了你，还是你找到了它，为什么？我有点像是在娱乐圈背景中长大的。我母亲是一名服装设计师。
I had a stepfather who was, you know, at the time was, you know, I just finished directing some plays on Broadway when I was a little bean. And then growing up, yeah, my mother says that I came to her when I was 15 and asked if it was okay if I'm an actor. At 15. At 15. And she said, yes, of course, son, whatever you want to do. And then, and then I started.
我有一个继父，你知道，当时他，我还是个小不点的时候，他刚刚导演了百老汇的一些戏剧。然后在我成长过程中，是的，我母亲说我15岁时去找她，问她如果我想成为一名演员可不可以。在15岁时。在15岁时。她说，当然可以，儿子，你想做什么都行。然后，然后我就开始了。
So I was pretty self-motivated and, you know, enrolled in a theater arts program, which will, you know, you might even know, the, was up in North Toronto. Leah Pozlin's theater group. I don't know if you ever came across that, but it was a wonderful person. They're named Rose Dubin. But anyway, so I was super self-motivated. You know, I auditioned for the performing arts high school. And I was at the library.
所以我很有内驱力，你知道的，报名参加了一个戏剧艺术项目，这个项目，你知道，你甚至可能知道，就在北多伦多。莉亚·波兹林（Leah Pozlin）的戏剧团。我不知道你有没有接触过，但那是个非常好的人。他们的名字叫罗斯·杜宾（Rose Dubin）。但不管怎样，我超级有内驱力。你知道的，我为表演艺术高中去试镜。我当时在图书馆。
I was reading. I was just, you know, taking acting classes with a hug and respect for acting. I'm 17, you know, doing the Stanislavski voice work. And I, you know, I ended up getting an agent at the, at the, at Leah Pozlin's because I was playing Mercutio and Romeo and Juliet. And so I guess that was my first big break. Oh, that's cool. And you're like, this, this tastes pretty great.
我在看书。我当时只是，你知道，在上表演课，对表演充满敬意。我当时17岁，你知道的，练习斯坦尼斯拉夫斯基的发声练习。然后我，我最终在莉亚·波兹林那里找到了一位经纪人，因为我在《罗密欧与朱丽叶》里扮演茂丘西奥。所以我想那是我的第一个重大突破。哦，太酷了。而你当时觉得，这，这感觉挺不错的。
Yeah, I got an agent. I started doing some commercials, sold some corn flakes and some cola. And you drove all, and you drove all the way out here by yourself from Toronto. And you're still not an American citizen, which I think is kind of cool. I get it. It's cool and not cool. I got in my first car when I was 20 and I drove to Hollywood. And of course, when I got here, they wanted to change my name.
对，我签了经纪人。我开始拍一些商业广告，卖玉米片和可乐。然后你一个人从多伦多一路开车开到了这里。而且你现在还不是美国公民，我觉得这挺酷的。我懂。这既酷又不酷。我20岁时坐上了我的第一辆车，开向了好莱坞。当然，当我到那儿时，他们想让我改名。
Really? Yeah, they were like Keanu, it's too ethnic. Oh, Lord. I mean, literally like the day I, I mean, I remember I had driven across the country and remember they told me and I was like stomping up and down along the beach in Santa Monica going, what the fuck? Yeah, yeah. You know, and then I was like, okay, well, what's my name going to be?
真的吗？对，他们觉得基努，这名字太有少数族裔色彩了。天哪。我的意思是，字面意思，就在我，我的意思是，我记得我一路开车跨越了整个国家，然后我记得他们告诉我这个，我当时在圣莫尼卡的沙滩上气得直跺脚，心想：“这特么算什么？”对，对。你知道的，然后我就想：“好吧，那我叫什么名字好呢？”
And I was like, Templeton. Or like, anyway. Did they pitch you any names or did they ask you to go think up some? Yeah, so eventually I came up with my first and middle initial. So I was Casey Reeves. No way. No way. For a couple of...
我就想：坦普顿（Templeton）。或者诸如此类的。他们有给你推荐什么名字吗，还是让你自己去想几个？对，所以我最后用了我名字的首字母和中间名首字母。所以我当时叫凯西·里维斯（Casey Reeves）。不可能。不可能。有那么一阵子……
That would work? Yeah, Casey Reeves. That would be good. Oh my God, please. He'd be a great Casey. No, man, but then I had like auditions and they'd be like Casey and I wouldn't even look up. And eventually I went back to my agents and I was like, I can't change my name.
这行得通？对，凯西·里维斯。那倒挺好。哦天哪，拜托。他会是个极好的凯西。不，老兄，但后来我有试镜时，他们会叫“凯西”，我都不会抬头。最后我回到我的经纪人那里，我说：“我不能改名。”
Like one of the first plays, one first play I ever did was, was playing John Proctor and one of the lines is just like, you know, because it is my name, because I can have no other and I was the crucible. That's the signal. I was the crucible. And I just thought that was just running through my head, you know. And so, so with Ted, was Bill and Ted's the one thing that really like, how did that come to you?
就像我演的第一部戏，演的第一部戏剧是扮演约翰·普罗克托（John Proctor），其中有一句台词大概就是，你知道的，“因为这是我的名字，因为我不能有别的名字，”我当时演的是《萨勒姆的女巫》（The Crucible）。这就是那个信号。我演的是《萨勒姆的女巫》。我当时就觉得这句话一直在我的脑海里回响，你知道的。所以，对于《比尔和泰德》，《比尔和泰德历险记》是那部真正让你，这个机会是怎么找上你的？
And that, cause that kind of put you on the map for us to know who you are. Right? Yeah, I think for me, probably, you know, the biggest, another big break that we all need is, I was in a film called River's Edge. Oh my God. Right, right, right, right, right. Of course. With Crispin Glover.
而且那，因为那确实让我们知道了你是谁，把你推上了地图。对吧？对，我想对我来说，可能，你知道的，最大的，另一个我们需要的大突破是，我曾参演过一部叫《大河边缘》（River's Edge）的电影。哦，天哪。对，对，对，对，对。当然。和克里斯平·格洛弗（Crispin Glover）一起。
With the amazing, beautiful Crispin Glover. Yeah, yeah, yeah. To that movie. What I do for my fucking friends. And to watch that artist work, you know, talk about being and seeing an artist kind of deal with what the expectation of a role could be or how you could even act, how you could even be in a scene. You know, for me, it was a revelation.
和了不起、美丽的克里斯平·格洛弗一起。对，对，对。那部电影。我为了我特么的朋友们都做了些什么。看着那个艺术家工作，你知道的，谈到亲眼见到并观察一个艺术家如何应对角色的预期，或者你如何去表演，你如何能在一场戏里自处。对我来说，那是一个启示。
So he was doing it completely differently than what you thought it was going to be just reading the script. Yeah. I think everybody's standing there in the room. Right. I mean, it was just, but, but he had the essence of what the role was. Yeah. And he had his unique voice on it, which I think we all do, right?
所以他的表演方式完全不同于你光读剧本时的想象。对。我想当时房间里的每个人都有同感。我的意思是，那简直是，但他抓住了这个角色的精髓。对。并且他在其中融入了他独特的嗓音，我想我们都有，对吧？
Yeah. We all have our own voice, but the way that he was performing and understanding the form of acting too, the way that he understood the camera, the way he understood choreography and where he would go with his voice, the choices that he would make, was something to me that was revelatory. I do love that part of what we do. You know, like the audience doesn't read the script before they see the movie. So they have no proof.
对。我们都有自己的声音，但他表演的方式以及对表演形式的理解，他理解镜头的方式，他理解编舞的方式以及他运用嗓音的方式，他所做出的选择，对当时的我都具有启示意义。我确实很喜欢我们所做工作的那一部分。你知道的，观众在看电影之前并没有读过剧本。所以他们没有任何预设。
They don't know what they don't know. So they get what they get and they don't get upset unless somebody sucks. And, you know, like usually people don't suck, you know, for people that are taking these big swings and you just kind of, but I bet if these, if the audience would think for one second, like if you read all these lines on a page, would you imagine this kind of performance and nine times out of 10, the answer would be no. That's what everybody on the set is dealing with. So the, the, the instinct is to criticize it and say, Oh no, that you can't play the
他们不知道他们所不知道的。所以他们看到什么就是什么，只要没人演得烂，他们是不会生气的。而且，你知道，通常人们都不会演得烂，你知道的，对于那些敢于大胆尝试的人，你只是，但如果，如果观众哪怕想上一秒钟，如果你在纸上读到这些台词，你会想象出这种表演吗？十有八九答案是否定的。这也是片场每个人都在应对的情况。所以，本能是去批评它，说：“哦不，你不能这样演这个角色。”
character like that. You know, a director will come up and say, Hey, easy with that. And let's go over here and take the character this direction. You know, and, but the audience is never going to do that. So if an actor just needs to push back just a little bit and say, well, hang on, I'm still going to get us there, but it might be a little wiggly through here. Like just let me do that. Let me play it like this.
导演会走过来说：“嘿，收敛点。我们往这边走，把这个角色带向这个方向。”你知道的，但观众永远不会那样做。所以如果一个演员只需要稍微推回一下说：“等一下，我依然能把大家带到目的地，但中间可能有点曲折。就让我这么做吧。让我这样演。”
And, and with that, you get, you know, so many artists, but you know, you get like Christopher Walken. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, you can't write that. You just, that's performance and you, you can't give it a false negative because it sounds and looks different than what you imagined. Do you remember, do you remember Crispin Glover and Wild at Heart? And he's, he's in that he's placed the, he's got all those flashback scenes and he's the
然后通过这种方式，你会得到，你知道，这么多的艺术家，但你知道的，你会得到像克里斯托弗·沃肯（Christopher Walken）这样的人。对，没错。对，你写不出那种效果。那完全是表演，你不能因为它的声音和外表跟你想象的不同，就给它一个虚假的差评。你记得吗，你还记得克里斯平·格洛弗在《我心狂野》（Wild at Heart）里的表演吗？他在里面扮演那个，他有所有那些闪回的镜头，他就是那个
guy who's got, he's like, he's got, he's got, he's got cockroaches in his underwear and they, and he's cutting bread, cutting bread. I just, I love Wild at Heart. It's one of my favorite movies. And you just hear, I forget his character was like, what are you doing? And then he's cutting, then he goes, I'm making my lunch. And he's just in this like underwear stuffed with, and you're like, what a wild choice. And you just know that David Lynch gave him a ton of room.
家伙，他有，他内裤里塞满了蟑螂，然后他们，他在切面包，切面包。我真是太喜欢《我心狂野》了。它是我最喜欢的电影之一。然后你听到，我忘了他的角色当时是怎么说的，大概是“你在干什么？”然后他在切面包，接着他说：“我在做我的午餐。”他就穿着塞满了东西的内裤，你会觉得：真是个狂野的选择。你就是知道大卫·林奇给了他极大的发挥空间。
Like piano, like, you know, not that there's, there isn't art and, and challenges in Bill and Ted's excellent adventure and, and, and the sequel and this and speed and all of these things. They are, you know, what people call, you know, popcorn movies, but they're just as difficult of roles and movies to make where you, did you have any kind of trepidation from going to being so trained to going into these kinds of things and worrying about the perception of them? Um, at the time, no, man, I was trying to work.
就像钢琴一样，当然，并不是说……《比尔和泰德历险记》以及它的续集、《生死时速》这些作品里没有艺术和挑战。它们就是人们所说的爆米花电影，但要拍好这些角色和电影同样困难，你从接受过严格训练转型去拍这些作品时，有没有过任何忐忑，或者担心别人怎么看？呃，当时没有，老兄，我只是在努力工作。
Yeah, yeah. For sure. For sure. And I, you know, and I love like for the script of, of Bill and Ted's excellent adventure. The audition process for that film is almost legendary. I mean, I think everybody read for that. And it was. Oh, really?
对，对，肯定的，肯定的。而且我，你知道，我很喜欢《比尔和泰德历险记》的剧本。这部电影的试镜过程简直是个传奇。我的意思是，我觉得每个人都去试镜了。确实是。哦，真的吗？
But I got to meet Alex Winter. Yeah. At that time and, uh, we just had one of those things where you like, you're both in the waiting room to go audition and you're like, Hey, Hey. And then we started talking and he's like, Yeah, I ride bike because I'm a helmet. I go like, I ride. And he's like, Yeah, well, and then he's like, I went to in my, in my U film school and he started talking about movies and like, and then we were working on the, we started audition
但我遇到了亚历克斯·温特。对，就在那时候，呃，我们俩当时都在候诊室准备试镜，然后你就说：“嘿，嘿。”接着我们开始聊天，他说：“对啊，我骑自行车，因为我戴头盔。”我接着说：“我骑车。”然后他说：“对啊，还有……”然后他说：“我在我的电影学院里……”接着我们开始谈论电影，然后我们就开始……我们开始试镜
and, you know, with those, with those roles, he and I both kind of both independently came to the idea of Comedia Del Arte and the physicality of these kind of classical Comedia characters. And so like there was Bill and there was Ted. And so how would you, what was the physicalness? How did they play off of each other and a kind of punch and Judy kind of way? But like, um, and so we had a, we had an instant kind of vernacular and a way to approach these roles that, that was really exciting and hilarious. Yeah.
而且，你知道的，对于那些角色，我和他不知怎么的，都各自独立地想到了即兴喜剧和这些古典即兴喜剧角色的肢体语言。所以，这里有比尔，那里有泰德。那么，你会怎么……那种肢体动作是怎样的？他们是如何以一种类似“庞奇和朱迪”木偶戏的方式互相配合的？但是，呃……所以我们有一种即兴的黑话，以及一种真正令人兴奋且搞笑的方法来处理这些角色。对。
It was just so much fun to play. And that was something that you guys, I first of all written by the, by the great Ed Solomon too, right? I mean, great, great writer. Chris Matheson. Yeah. Just so, and was that once you guys kind of keyed into that? You know, like you said, there were so many people auditioning for it.
演起来真的太有趣了。而且这是你们……首先，这也是由伟大的埃德·所罗门写的，对吧？我的意思是，一个非常非常伟大的作家。克里斯·马森。对。太棒了，当你们俩找到这个诀窍之后……你知道的，就像你说的，有那么多人来试镜。
Was it just like you hit it? And George Carlin. And then you have George Carlin. Oh, George Carlin. I forgot that Carlin was in that too. What was that like, man? Man, he was so nice. He's super low key.
是不是就像你们一拍即合？还有乔治·卡林。然后你们还有乔治·卡林。哦，乔治·卡林。我忘了卡林也参演了那部电影。那是什么感觉，老兄？老兄，他太友好了。他超级低调。
He and Alex would go talk politics and do all of those things. Yeah. One of my, I mean, he was so lovely. I remember he, uh, he's one of the few people I've asked for an autograph and he, and I said, can I have an autograph? And he was like, sure. And he wrote, uh, Keoni, fuck you. And then I was like, oh my God, George has said that to me.
他和亚历克斯会去谈论政治以及所有这些事情。是的。我……我的意思是，他太可爱了。我记得他……他是少数几个我向他要过签名的人之一，然后我问：“我能要个签名吗？”他回答：“当然。”然后他写下：“基努，去你妈的。”接着我就想：“哦天哪，乔治竟然对我说了这个。”
I was like, cool. And I took it so personally and then I found out down, down the years that he would actually write that to other people. Yeah. It wasn't special, but it's special that you did that, man. Is there somebody that you got over your years other than George or are these people that you were just completely blown away, starstruck by? Gosh, so many.
当时我觉得：“太酷了。”我把这当成了私人恩怨，结果多年后我才发现，他其实也会给其他人写这个。是的。这并不特别，但你这么做真的很特别，老兄。除了乔治之外，有没有哪个人是你这么多年来……或者说有没有哪些人让你彻底折服、惊为天人？天哪，有好多。
So many. So many. I mean, I, I asked for an autograph from Lou Reed for a friend. He was like, shoot. And then he kind of scribbled it. I think I carved it in your hand. Some pathetic piece of paper. Yeah.
太多了。太多了。我的意思是，我曾向娄·里德为朋友要过一个签名。他说：“拿去。”然后他随便草草签了一下。我觉得我是在你手上刻下来的。写在某张破纸上。对。
Sure. Yeah. Dude, what do you, what do you think about? It seems like, man, again, I just love, you've just had such an interesting, like really, really, um, unique trajectory in, in longevity. And then it seems like the last couple of years, people, I feel like every five years, people re-appreciate you like a new group of people are like, oh my God, Keanu Reeves. And the last couple of years, it's true.
没错。对。老兄，你觉得……感觉就像是，老兄，我真的很喜欢你，你的演艺生涯真的是太有趣了，真的非常独特，而且有着长久的生命力。然后似乎在过去几年里，人们……我觉得每隔五年，大家就会重新欣赏你一次，就像新的一批人会说：“哦天哪，基努·里德。”在过去的几年里，确实如此。
And people go like, and then you've just become this thing in the last couple of years, like everybody has recognized, and it's obviously because of a lifetime of being a good guy. People are starting to really recognize that about you. And you've been, you've kind of crossed over, and I don't mean to embarrass you into this kind of weird look, man, whether you like it or not, and you can, you can avert your eyes so you don't have to look at me when I say this. You've been a sex symbol for a long time. None of us have been, have that, have that weight.
大家都会说……然后在过去的几年里，你不知不觉成了这样一种存在——每个人都认可了这一点，这显然是因为你一辈子都是个好人。人们开始真正从你身上认识到这一点。你已经跨界了，我不是想让你难堪，让你露出这种奇怪的表情，老兄，不管你愿不愿意，你可以把视线移开，这样当我这么说的时候你就不用看着我了。你当性感男神很久了。我们当中没有人有那种……有那种分量。
Welcome to the club. Yeah. And then you've kind of gone, and so you're like an actor and a sex symbol. And then you've kind of, you've now gone into this kind of like iconic status, like with, with culturally, no, I mean, by the way, you're 58. I know. I'm not coming on to you. You look great for 58.
欢迎来到这个俱乐部。对。然后你又跨越了，所以你既是个演员，也是个性感男神。然后你现在又进入了这种具有标志性的地位，从文化层面上来说……不，我是说，顺便问一句，你58岁了。我知道。我不是在勾引你。你58岁看起来状态太棒了。
He is actually a great match for you though, Will. I mean, think about his, his, his passions. We would be great if either of us were gay, we'd be perfect for each other. No. But, but I, but it's, it's, it must be kind of a bit of a trip because you're like, I'm still me, and you haven't done anything different. You get up every morning and have your coffee the same way, and then all of a sudden you're right.
不过，维尔，他确实和你挺般配的。我的意思是，想想他的那些爱好……如果我们俩之中有一个是同性恋，那我们会非常完美，简直绝配。不。但是，但是……但它一定有点像是一场奇妙的旅程，因为你会觉得：“我依然是我。”你并没有做任何不同的事。你每天早上起来，用同样的方式喝咖啡，然后突然之间，你就……对。
Has it been kind of trippy in a way? Yeah, I mean, I think all of us have kind of had the experience of the before and the now with communication. And so I think, you know, certainly now in a now, you know, to your point, Will, I mean, I think right now I'm, I'm, is, you know, nice is nice and can be super nice and I'm really grateful for it. I do know that that is fickle. Yeah.
从某种程度上来说，这不是很魔幻吗？对，我的意思是，我觉得我们所有人都有过通过交流来感受“过去”和“现在”的经历。所以我觉得，当然了，现在……说到当下，维尔，我的意思是，我觉得现在的我……你知道的，人好就是好，也可以超级好，对此我真的非常感激。我也知道这很无常。对。
Yeah. But, but, but, you know, I think, you know, memes and stuff like that, you know, I remember the first time someone showed me sad Keanu. And I was like, what is this? Yeah, yeah. You know, I was used to paparazzi photos, but I wasn't used to a paparazzi, you know, I could see how like, you know, I was used to tabloid communication, right? Right.
对。但是，但是……你知道，我觉得各种表情包之类的东西，你知道的，我记得第一次有人向我展示“悲伤基努”的时候。我就想：“这是什么？”对，对。你知道的，我习惯了狗仔队的照片，但我并不习惯狗仔队拍的……我能理解……你知道的，我习惯了小报的传播方式，对吧？对。
And so this became, that was the before and now the now is something else. And, you know, and for me, I was like, I was just eating a sandwich. And I was like editing, you know, I was like, kind of like down and like, and then, and I came up with, you know, in order to kind of preserve self preservation was like, you can see a picture that can tell a thousand words. But that's always not going to be all the story to tell. All right. I mean, that kind of lensing or focusing and then the way it gets shared or transmitted.
所以这成了……那已经是过去式了，而现在则是另一回事。而且，对我来说，我当时只是在吃三明治，然后我当时……你知道的，有点情绪低落，就像是垂头丧气的样子，然后……为了自我保护，我想通了一件事：一张照片可以表达一千个字，但它永远无法呈现故事的全部。好吧。我的意思是，那种镜头视角或焦点，以及它被分享或传播的方式。
Anyway, long story short, that was pretty fucking funny. And weird. It was funny and weird. It's fucking weird. It's fucking weird. And like, here you are on a candle and you're carrying a lamp. You know, do you ever think about the kids today who are coming up who were, you know, thinking about like when you were coming up and you were doing Bill and Ted's and all
总之，长话短说，那真的他妈的太搞笑了。而且很诡异。又搞笑又诡异。真他妈诡异。真他妈诡异。就像，你出现在蜡烛上，手里还拿着一盏灯。你知道的，你有没有想过现在那些崭露头角的年轻人，当他们想到你当年刚出道，拍了《比尔和泰德》以及所有
these great movies and you shot out of a cannon. Can you imagine having to have the scrutiny that there is now? Yeah, no. I mean, it's a scrutiny and responsibilities, right? Right. I mean, I think. And you're a kid, so you don't know anybody. You're kind of dumb.
这些伟大的电影时，你就像从大炮里发射出来一样一炮而红。你能想象去承受现在这种无孔不入的审视吗？是的，绝对不能。我的意思是，那是审视和责任，对吧？对。我的意思是，我觉得……
We're all dumb when we were kids. Yeah. Yeah, I unfortunately kept that going. But, um, yeah, the, the, um, yeah, I mean, I do. I, you know, I've heard of just a lot of artists having the pressure to be on social media in order to get a job. Right. Right.
而且你当时还是个孩子，所以你谁也不认识。你有点愚蠢。我们年轻的时候都很蠢。对。是的，不幸的是我一直保持着这种状态。但是，呃……是的，呃……是的，我的意思是，确实如此。我听说很多艺术家为了得到一份工作，承受着必须活跃在社交媒体上的压力。对吧？对。
Like to even get in the room. How many followers do they have? Yeah, the following kind of aspect to the kind of capitalistic idea of it. But, um, yeah, I mean, I bet it's tough. I bet it's tough, but also I'm sure it's pleasurable for some people too. Right. You know, and there's artistry to it and involvement and creativity, but, um, I think, I think the, the now is definitely more intense pressure on your private life than the before.
就像为了能进入面试房间一样。他们有多少粉丝？对，这种粉丝数量的方面，迎合了一种资本主义的想法。但是，呃……是的，我的意思是，我敢打赌这很艰难。我敢打赌这很艰难，但同时我也确信这对某些人来说也是一种乐趣。对吧？你知道的，这其中有艺术性、参与感和创造力，但是，呃……我觉得，我觉得现在的生活对你私生活的压力，绝对比过去要激烈得多。
Yeah. I mean, the before had a lot of pressure too, but I think the, the now is even more. Yeah, for sure. Well, I mean, when you said you were 58, it's like your, Keanu Reeves is going to be 60 in two years. You've had, you've gotten a lot of shit done. Yeah. I mean.
对。我的意思是，过去也有很大的压力，但我觉得现在的压力甚至更大。是的，肯定的。好吧，我的意思是，当你刚才说你58岁的时候，这就好像是……基努·里德两年后就要60岁了。你已经完成了好多大事。是的。我的意思是……
You've been busy, motherfucker. Yeah. I know, but I haven't hit the 100. I want to be, I want, I haven't hit the 100. I want to be a hundred too. No, no, but a hundred years old, but also a hundred films. A hundred films. Oh, how many you got?
你一直都很忙，混蛋。是的。我知道，但我还没到100部。我想成为……我还没到100部。我也想活到100岁。不，不，不仅是100岁，还要拍100部电影。100部电影。哦，你现在拍了多少部了？
Yeah. I, I don't know. I think I'm in the 70s. Yeah. Well, you've got time. You got plenty of time. Just don't get stuck directing a bunch of them. And, you know, you'll lose a bunch of time.
对。我，我不知道。我想我大概在70多部吧。好吧，你有的是时间。你有的是充足的时间。只要别陷进去执导一大堆电影就行了。那样的话你会浪费掉很多时间。
Yeah. Wait, speaking of though. Okay. So I want to get into John Wick because I have a bunch of questions. Okay. So first of all, let me just start. We do have a connection because I'm kind of stating the obvious here. We have the same personal trainer. Yeah.
对。等等，不过说起来……好吧。所以我想聊聊《疾速追杀》，因为我有一堆问题。好吧。所以首先，让我先开头。我们确实有点联系，因为我这可以说是显而易见了。我们有同一个私人教练。对。
So Patrick Murphy is fantastic. The best. The best. I love him. He's the greatest. And he's trained you quite a bit as I understand. And he's nothing but incredible kind words to say about you. And like me, he's always blown away.
所以帕特里克·摩菲太棒了。最棒的。最棒的。我爱死他了。他是最伟大的。据我所知，他没少训练你。而且他对你的评价全都是难以置信的赞美之词。和我一样，他总是被惊艳到。
Like a lot of people are blown away by the fact that you, you do all your own stunts. I don't do stunts. But you had to in the first John Wick. You're falling on your back. He doesn't call them stunts. Oh, sorry. You do. First of all, you guys have the same trainer.
就像很多人对你亲自完成所有特技动作感到震惊一样。我不做特技。但在第一部《疾速追杀》里你必须亲自上阵。你要往后倒。他不把那叫作特技。哦，抱歉。你做的。首先，你们俩用同一个教练。
I mean, is he so exhausted after working with Keanu that by the time he gets to you, he just, because there's a real fucking there. I mean, this is okay. This is let's stand up and make a bagel. Sean, stand up and make a bagel. Here we go. There. Yeah.
我的意思是，他跟基努合作完之后是不是累得筋疲力尽，以至于等他来训练你的时候，他只会……因为那里真的他妈的……我的意思是，好吧。我们要站起来做一个贝果三明治。肖恩，站起来做一个贝果三明治。我们开始吧。就是这样。对。
So anyway, but okay. So you do your own action. Is that right? No, it's a big difference, right? Because if I'm there, if John Wick gets hit by a car, I'm not doing that. That's a stun. If John Wick is in a fight scene, I can do the fighting. And if I can do a judo throw, or if I'm going to fall on the ground,
所以不管怎样，但是……好吧。所以你自己做动作戏，是这样吗？不，这有很大区别，对吧？因为如果我在现场，如果约翰·威克被车撞了，那不是我做的。那是特技。如果约翰·威克在打斗戏里，我可以自己打。如果我能做一个柔道摔投，或者我要摔倒在地上……
but let me say something, jump off a bill. I'm sorry. No, no, but let me just say something. Because you fall because I've seen them. And so I'm looking at them and it's your face falling on the ground. Yeah. Well, that's falling action. But no, but that's the lens, right?
但让我说一句，从楼上跳下来……对不起。不，不，但让我说一句。因为你摔倒了——因为我看过那些镜头。所以我看着它们，那是你的脸摔在地上。对。好吧，那是跌落动作。不，但那是镜头的问题，对吧？
So maybe I'll do the double action. I'll do the, all right. All right. I mean, listen, I get to ride some horses. I get to drive some cars. I get to like, you know, run and jump and do a lot of, you know, interactive fight sequences. But Patrick praises you like no end because he just says,
所以也许我会做双人替身动作。我会做……好吧。好吧。我的意思是，听着，我得骑骑马。我得开开车。我得……你知道的，奔跑、跳跃，做很多互动式的打斗戏。但帕特里克对你赞不绝口，因为他说……
you have such a high threshold for pain. You're like the second, if you hurt yourself, you're back in the game right away. Like I heard or I read somewhere that you, like the first day or the first week you're shooting, John Wick 2, that you injured yourself and you just got up and just kept going. Like it's like a football player. Yeah.
你的痛阈太高了。你就像是……如果你受伤了，你马上就能重返赛场。就像我听说或在什么地方读到过，你在拍《疾速追杀2》的第一天或第一周就受伤了，而你只是爬起来继续开拍。就像个橄榄球运动员一样。对。
Yeah, there is, but I mean, but that's the kind of the joy of it too. Isn't it? Like it's not easy. I don't know about that. Once you get past 45, it's not super enjoyable. I mean, I know, but if you can do it, right? If you can try, if you can try, if you can climb, if you can climb the mountain.
是的，确实如此，但我的这也是其中的乐趣所在，对吧？它并不容易。我可不这么觉得。一旦你过了45岁，这就一点也不好玩了。我的意思是，我懂，但如果你能做到的话，对吧？如果你能尝试，如果你能尝试……如果你能登上一座高山。
But doing it, it's got to be a lot harder now. Who cares, man? Hard, smart, whatever. Shoot, come on, man. I fucking love this guy. It's rainy, it's hot, it's whatever. It's like, you're not comfortable, whatever. Get out of here.
但现在做这些肯定要难得多。谁在乎呢，老兄？管它难不难，聪明不聪明，随便啦。开拍吧，老兄。我他妈太爱这个家伙了。外面下着雨也好，天气很热也罢，随便什么都行。这就好比，你觉得不舒服，管它呢。滚开吧。
Tell him, Keanu, Keanu, tell Bateman, you fucking let's go, Bateman, what the fuck dude? Fuck it. All right, listen, but wait, then I heard this too, from Patrick told me this, that people stop you on the street and give you feedback or ideas about the John Wick series. You should do this.
告诉他，基努，基努，告诉贝特曼，你他妈的……我们走吧，贝特曼，这他妈算怎么回事啊？去他的。好吧，听着，但是等等，后来我还听说这个——帕特里克告诉我，人们会在街上拦住你，对《疾速追杀》系列提出反馈或建议。你应该这样拍。
You should do that. Is that true? Yeah, once in a while. And there's some good ideas and stuff, but... Really? Yeah, I mean, the world, I mean, I think that's what's really... I'd be like, I think I got it. But I really appreciate it.
你真该那样。真的吗？对，偶尔吧。里面有些挺好的想法之类的，但是……真的吗？对，我是说，世界，我是说，我觉得那才是真正的……我当时会想，我觉得我懂了。不过我真的很感激。
I really appreciate with John Wick how the world has opened up with the idea of a high table. There's so much mystery in films, but in a weird way, somehow it all makes sense and you authentically feel that everyone has a past. Yes, I love that. Because the first one is like, you fucking kill my dog, I fucking kill you.
我真的很感激《疾速追杀》通过“大陆酒店”的概念把世界观拓宽了。电影里有很多神秘感，但神奇的是，这一切又都说得通，而且你能真切地感受到每个人都有过去。是的，我喜欢那样。因为第一部的感觉就像是，你他妈杀了我狗，我他妈弄死你。
And you're off to the races, right? And that's what the thing is. And then it's just kind of grew and grew and grew. I'm kidding, it's deeper than that. But it grew and grew from there. But not really. But not really. But it's so cool.
然后故事就一发不可收拾了，对吧？事情就是这样。接着它就不断地发展、发展、发展。我开玩笑的，内涵比这更深。但它就是从那开始不断发展。不过也不完全是。不过也不完全是。但真的很酷。
It's really, really cool. Revenge and freedom. Is there anything you heard over the years and that feedback from your fans? Like, what is the main people... What is the main thing people say? I think people try to connect why all is happening. And they try to connect, like, maybe my wife is really...
真的、真的很酷。复仇与自由。这些年来，你有没有听到粉丝们的一些反馈？比如，大家最常说的是什么？……大家讨论的核心是什么？我觉得大家试图把这一切发生的原因串联起来。他们试图去联想，比如，我的妻子是不是真的很……
Is she really dead? Is she part of the high table? Is the character Winston? Is he really pulling all of the strings? What's the Bowery King? Is it a fever dream? Is John Wick... So we have people trying to kind of connect dots
她真的死了吗？她是大陆酒店的人吗？温斯顿这个角色？他真的在幕后操纵一切吗？包厘街之王呢？这是一场狂热的梦吗？约翰·威克……所以大家都在试着把线索串联起来，
and try and kind of get a big overview of the story and get to it. It's really cool. Yeah, it's kind of fun. And we will be right back. Our next partner is Athletic Greens. I take AG1 by Athletic Greens literally every day. I gave AG1 a try, I don't know, two years ago, maybe? I wanted better gut health.
试图对整个故事有一个宏观的了解并理清头绪。真的很酷。对，挺有意思的。我们马上回来。我们的下一个合作伙伴是 Athletic Greens。我真的是每天都在喝 Athletic Greens 的 AG1。我大概两年前开始尝试 AG1 的吧？我当时想要更好的肠道健康。
I wanted more energy. I wanted a simple way to take vitamins and minerals that were important to my body. I didn't want to have to take all these supplements. I wanted one place. And AG1 is that place. I put it in the thing. I shake the thing.
我想要更多精力。我想要一种简单的方式来摄取对身体至关重要的维生素和矿物质。我不想吃那么一大堆补剂。我希望有一个产品能搞定一切。而 AG1 就是这样的产品。我把它倒进杯子里。我摇一摇杯子。
I down the thing. And it's so good for my body and it tastes great. This is the best option. This is the best option for easy, optimal nutrition out there. You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, whole foods, source, superfoods, probiotics, and adaptogens to help you start your day right. This blend of ingredients supports your gut health,
我一口气喝下。它对我的身体太好了，而且味道超棒。这是目前最好的选择。这是获取简单、最佳营养的最好选择。你只需要一勺 AG1，就能吸收 75 种高品质的维生素、矿物质、全食来源超级食物、益生菌和适应原，帮你开启完美的一天。这种成分组合支持你的肠道健康、
your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, recovery, focus, and aging. You know what I love most about it? You can mix it with water when you're traveling. You can put it in a smoothie like with all the other stuff that you make your smoothies with. And it tastes great. It tastes great any way you want to roll.
你的神经系统、你的免疫系统、你的精力、恢复力、专注力和抗衰老。你知道我最喜欢它什么吗？旅行时你可以把它和水混在一起喝。你可以把它放进奶昔里，就像你做奶昔时加的那些东西一样。而且味道很棒。不管你怎么搭配，味道都超级棒。
I mean, it's the healthiest way to start your day for me, and I know it will be for you too. Right now, it's time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop of AG1 and a cup of water every day. You don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health. Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply
我是说，对我来说这是开启一天最健康的方式，我知道对你来说也是如此。现在，是时候重获健康，用便捷的日常营养武装你的身体了。每天只需一勺 AG1 和一杯水。你不需要成百上千种不同的药丸和补剂来维持健康。Athletic Greens 将在你的首次购买中赠送你一年的免费
of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartlist to give AG1 a try. That's athleticgreens.com slash smartlist. Check it out. All right, back to the show. When you do a film like the John Wick films, do you... What is your...
支持免疫系统的维生素 D，以及五份免费便携旅行装。访问 athleticgreens.com 斜杠 smartlist 来试一试 AG1。网址是 athleticgreens.com 斜杠 smartlist。快去看看吧。好了，回到节目中。当你拍像《疾速追杀》这样的电影时，你会……你的……
Because they are so physical. What's your... When you rap, what is your sort of recovery? Are you like, I need four weeks on a beach or four weeks at home with the door shut or I need to like go to parrot? Like what do you do to like recover from those really grueling movies?
因为它们对体力要求太高了。你的……杀青后，你的恢复方式是什么？你会想，我需要在海滩上待四周，或者在家里把门关上待四周，或者我需要去——比如你会做什么来从那些极其折磨人的电影中恢复过来？
After when I get home after I finish filming them. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it starts with collapse. Yeah. But it's an interesting thing. I don't know if you guys have found this, but like, I don't know, coming off the road or coming off the series or the work that you're doing.
拍完电影回家之后。对，对。对，一开始就是瘫倒。对。但这是个很有趣的现象。我不知道你们有没有这种感觉，就像，我不知道，结束巡演、结束剧集或完成手头的工作之后。
You can be really tired, but then there's also a restlessness. Yeah. I don't know if you've experienced that. Like, you know, I'm just going to stay home. Well, I'm just going to get up and go get something from the fridge. Right. You know, but there can also be the periods where like, don't talk to me.
你会觉得真的很累，但同时又会有一种坐立不安的感觉。对。我不知道你们有没有经历过这种感觉。就像，你知道的，“我今天就待在家里。”“嗯，我还是起来去冰箱拿点东西吧。”没错。你知道的，但也会有那种“别跟我说话”的时期。
No, I don't want to work. But then you're like, but there is a restlessness. And then once I get through the restlessness from it, then it's like I go into a world that I don't quite understand in the sense of like, how do I rest or who am I? What is the meaning of life? What am I doing? You're trying to reconnect with people, you know,
“不，我不想工作。”但接着你会想，但又有一种坐立不安感。然后，一旦我度过了那种坐立不安的阶段，我就会进入一个我不太理解的世界，比如：我该如何休息？我是谁？生命的意义是什么？我在干什么？你会试着重新与人建立联系，你知道的，
because making films of that kind of time scale, you're in a time machine. You know, you know, everyone around you, then you go away and you go down the river on your kind of independent journey. They're going down a river and then you have to meet up at the other side of that distance to travel. So so much of their lives have gone on. Yes, you can have contact, but you're not involved, you know,
因为制作那种时间跨度的电影，你就像是在一台时间机器里。你知道的，你了解周围的每个人，然后你离开了，开启了你自己的独立旅程。他们也在顺流而下，然后你们必须在漫长旅途的另一头重新汇合。所以他们生活中发生了那么多事。是的，你们可以保持联系，但你并没有参与其中，你知道的，
and so it's kind of in a weird way, syncing up to those around you and syncing back up to your life. You know, at the same time that you're totally exhausted, restless, questioning everything. And then of course you have the fear and desperation of being unemployed. Yeah. And then you want to, you know, then you're back into it. Is it as much of a draw for you as it was when you were just
所以在某种奇怪的程度上，这需要重新与周围的人同步，重新与你的生活同步。与此同时，你又筋疲力尽、坐立不安、对一切产生质疑。然后，当然了，你还要面对失业的恐惧和绝望。对。然后你想……你知道的，然后你又回到了那种状态。这对于现在的你来说，还像当年你只是
trying to make something of your career and something of yourself and carve something out? Because it seems like you're very respectful of life itself, like the real stuff as opposed to, you know, career stuff and making fake life. And having done so much, do you start, and I'm just, I'm sort of projecting myself, right? I mean, I'm 54 and you start thinking about what we're closer to death
想在事业上闯出名堂、成就自我、开辟一番天地时那样，具有巨大的吸引力吗？因为看起来你非常尊重生命本身，也就是真实的东西，而不是那些职业上的事情和虚假的生活。经历过这么多之后，你开始——我这算是在投射自我吧？我是说，我都 54 岁了，你开始思考我们距离死亡
than we are to birth. Oh, sorry, no way. 54. Well, I'm just, you know, like at what point do you, do you, like, what's the right ratio, you know? Do you think about, well, there are certainly, I'd like to play a role like this and a role like that or direct them this or don't do a player, whatever it is.
是不是比距离出生更近。哦，抱歉，不会吧。54 岁。我是说，你知道的，比如在哪个时间点，你，你，比如，什么才是正确的比例，你知道的？你会不会想，嗯，确实有这样的角色我想演，那样的角色我想演，或者去指导这个，或者别去演那个，不管是什么。
Like, do you have certain things you still want to check off? Yeah. Before you take a bigger vital life? Before I die? Yeah. Before you kick it? Before I kick it. Yeah, I mean, to answer your question, I mean,
比如，你还有没有什么想在生命迎来重大改变之前打勾完成的事情？在我死之前？对。在我嗝屁之前？在我嗝屁之前。对，我的意思是，回答你的问题，我是说，
I guess part of it is I still love acting and I still love the creativity of it. Yeah. And I still have ambition and hope. And I still want to do good work and work with people. And so I still want to do that. And I love the, I love the goal of a hundred. That's a hundred.
我想部分原因是我仍然热爱表演，我仍然热爱表演带来的创造力。对。我仍然有雄心壮志和希望。我仍然想做出好的作品，和优秀的人合作。所以我依然想这么做。而且我喜欢，我喜欢活到一百岁这个目标。那可是一百岁。
Yeah. And I want to be a hundred. That would be fun. Yeah. And any big thing pulling you in life, like, do you have certain places you'd like to travel to? Do you have a sport? Well, I'm hoping to do a play on Broadway.
对，我想活到一百岁。那一定很有趣。对。生活中还有什么大事在吸引着你吗？比如，有没有你想去旅游的特定地方？你有什么运动爱好吗？嗯，我希望能去百老汇演一出话剧。
Yeah. I mean, I haven't done that. Whoa. That sounds good. She's like, Sean, Sean's got his, and it's Tabasco theater. It's going to be hot. Tabasco.
对。我是说，我还没演过呢。哇。听起来不错。她就像是在说，肖恩，肖恩有他的……而且是在塔巴斯科剧院。那肯定很火爆。塔巴斯科。
Yeah. Yeah, they sponsored. It's not the Bolasco. Oh, nice. How do you know that? How do you know that? That's good. That's Tabasco.
对。对，他们赞助的。那不是波拉斯科剧院吗？哦，太好了。你怎么知道的？你怎么知道的？那挺好。那是塔巴斯科。
Hey, guys, check me out. Everything's hot. It's a hot night. It's Tabasco. It's a hot theater. You come in cool, you leave hot. Listen, I feel like this would be a generic question for anyone else other than you,
嘿，伙计们，来看看我。一切都很火辣。这是一个火热的夜晚。这是塔巴斯科。这是一个火热的剧院。你凉爽地来，火热地离开。听着，我觉得对除了你之外的任何人来说这都是个泛泛的问题，
but what's your favorite action movie? Oh, shit. One of your favorite action movies. One of them, yeah. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my God. And was there one... Do you think I'd have that, like,
但你最喜欢哪部动作电影？哦，靠。你最喜欢的动作电影之一。其中一部，对。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。有没有哪部……你觉得我会像把这个答案...
ready on my sleeve, right? Yeah. Like, oh, well, here's the list of the favorite action movies. Come on. I don't think I do. I don't have one. Okay, well, what do we mean by an action movie?
随时挂在嘴边，对吧？对。就像，哦，好吧，这是我最喜欢的动作电影清单。拜托。我觉得我没有。我没有最喜欢的。好吧，那我们所说的动作电影是指什么？
Like, you know, there's action movies. I mean, because it could be like a, it could be Bruce Lee and Enter the Dragon, or it could be Raiders of the Star. It could be Raiders of the, it could be Rollerball. Oh, is that an action movie? Rollerball.
就像，你知道的，有各种动作电影。我是说，因为它可以是，它可以是李小龙的《龙争虎斗》，或者它可以是《夺宝奇兵》。它可以是《夺宝奇兵》，它可以是《ローラーボール》（极速风暴）。哦，那是动作电影吗？极速风暴。
Sure, it is. A science fiction. Yeah, no, no, no. That was good. No, but you almost said Raiders of the Star. Could it be Chitty Chitty Bang Bang? Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
当然是。科幻片。对，不，不，不。那挺好的。不，但你刚才差点说成《夺宝奇星》。难道可以是《飞天万能车》？对。我是说，我不知道。
Yeah, that card gets hairy. I mean, I don't know. Sean Defund. But I just to answer your question, I mean, I grew up, I mean, like, what is it? Like The Towering Inferno? I mean, what about all of the chariot movies, right?
对，那确实有点扯。我是说，我不知道。肖恩·德丰。但为了回答你的问题，我是说，我是看着……我是说，比如什么？比如《火烧摩天楼》？我是说，那些所有的战车电影呢？
What about The Westerns? Gumball Rally. What action movies are we talking about? Oh, I mean, I guess Formative. I mean... I don't mean just people, like, moving in a scene. I just meant, like, people fighting.
那些西部片呢？《炮弹飞车》。我们到底在讨论什么动作电影？哦，我是说，我猜是具有开创性的。我是说……我指的不仅仅是人们在场景里走动。我只是指，比如人们打斗。
I know. I know. Fighting and blowing stuff. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Good for you, Keanu. Yeah, Sean. Define it.
我知道。我知道。打斗和炸东西。开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。真有你的，基努。对，肖恩。你来定义一下。
I mean... Listen, Keanu, John Wick 4, right? 4. There's 4. There's 4. It was released in March, and it's how great is... I can't wait to see it.
我是说……听着，基努，《疾速追杀4》，对吧？第 4 部。有 4 部。有 4 部。它在三月上映了，而且有多棒……我等不及要看了。
That's kind. Yeah, I can't wait. I'm a big, big fan of you and those movies and all your movies. We've taken up a lot of your time. Thank you for being here. I love you. You're the man.
你真好。对，我等不及了。我是你、那些电影以及你所有电影的超级大粉丝。我们占用了你很多时间。谢谢你来到这里。我爱你。你太棒了。
You're absolutely the man. You're very cool. Thank you, fellas. Thank you very much. Nice to meet y'all. I'm jealous that Sean had you as his guest. You've been on my wish list for, like, two and a half years,
你绝对是个传奇。你太酷了。谢谢你们，伙计们。非常感谢。很高兴认识你们。我真嫉妒肖恩能把你请来做嘉宾。你在我的愿望清单上已经待了大概两年半了，
so I'm so happy you're here. I can support that. Yeah. Yeah. Stop ducking me out there. You know, I'd like to spend more than just 57 minutes with you. Yeah.
所以我太高兴你能来了。我完全赞同。对。对。别再躲着我了。你知道的，我也想跟你一起度过不止 57 分钟的时光。对。
Come have dinner with us one night, all right? Yeah, that'd be so fun. Cool. Thank you. Do you live in Los Angeles, Keanu? I do. I'll just text me then.
哪天一起来跟我们吃个晚饭吧，好吗？对，那一定很有趣。酷。谢谢。基努，你住在洛杉矶吗？我住。那到时候发短信给我。
Text me the address. All right. Cool. All right. We love you. Thank you for being here, pal. Thanks for doing this. Thanks, man.
把地址发短信给我。好的。酷。好的。我们爱你。谢谢你来到这里，老朋友。谢谢你做这些。谢谢，老兄。
Thank you, buddy. Appreciate it. Thank you so much. See you, pal. Bye. Hey, guys. It's Keanu Reeves. That was Keanu Reeves.
谢谢你，伙计。非常感谢。再见，老朋友。拜拜。嘿，伙计们。我是基努·里维斯。刚才那是基努·里维斯。
Did you recognize him? I did recognize him. He has not changed. He's not changed a bit. 58 years old. He looks exactly the same. He's 32. He looks 32.
你认出他了吗？我认出来了。他一点都没变。他一点都没变。58 岁了。他看起来完全一样。他 32 岁。他看起来 32 岁。
Jason, you look like his older brother. You son of a bitch. You know what I mean? What? He's just skated over the fact that I know he didn't. Well, I call him stunts, but action sequences, whatever. He has too much respect for the people who do stunts. He's so unassuming.
杰森，你看起来像他大哥。你这个王八蛋。你知道我的意思吗？什么？他刚才轻描淡写地略过了我知道他没有做的事。好吧，我管这叫特技，不过是动作场面，随便啦。他太尊重那些做特技的人了。他太谦逊了。
He's so unassuming. And it's all real. But I'm not dissing them. I'm just saying, you know, take after take after take. Movie after movie after movie. Your body, it's just, I don't understand. Can you say, maybe, can you guys relate to this? When you were younger, did you have like, I didn't have an older brother.
他太谦逊了。而且全都是来真的。但我不是在贬低他们。我只是说，你知道的，一遍又一遍又一遍。一部电影接一部电影接一部电影。你的身体，我只是，我不理解。你们能，也许，你们能感同身受吗？你们年轻的时候，有没有那种——我没有哥哥。
So, but I had, I had guys who were like my dad. My dad, my, my godfather's son, Ward Brown was my idol. And he was a couple of years, he was like three years older than me. And everything he did, I wanted to do. He played hot. Everything. Cause I like looked up to him. I was like, Keanu, I could seize one of those guys that I've always been.
所以，但我有，我有那种像我爸爸一样的人。我爸爸的，我教父的儿子沃德·布朗就是我的偶像。他比我大几岁，大概比我大三岁。他做的每件事我都想做。他打得火热。每件事。因为我很崇拜他。我就觉得，基努就是那种我一直……
He's like a few years older and like, I just want to do it. What's he doing? He's totally right. And he's got that. He, he lives in that same space for me. I feel the same way about Pitt. I'm like, and everything. Hey, man, how's it going?
他比我大几岁，我就只想去做。他在干嘛？他完全是对的。而且他身上有那种特质。他，他对我来说就生活在那个同样的维度里。我对皮特也有同感。我就觉得，每件事。嘿，老兄，最近怎么样？
What are you doing? Like, yeah, we're just away. I'll do that. It's like a cool factor. I'll never, I'll never achieve. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you started out nice with it.
你在干嘛？就像，是的，我们只是出去玩。我也会那样。那是那种我永远也无法企及的酷。对。对。好吧，你一开始表现得还挺好。
You shared the same body instructor. What's his name? Body. Body instructor. What's it called? Shred. Shred. Guys, my brain's broken today.
你们共用同一个形体教练。他叫什么名字？形体教练。形体教练。叫什么来着？Shred。Shred。伙计们，我今天脑子短路了。
A trainer, like a personal trainer. Like a body trainer, right? Body instructor. Body instructor. Listen. But he also seems, he's so humble and unassuming. So humble. And I love him.
一个教练，就像私人教练。就像形体教练，对吧？形体教练。形体教练。听着。但他同时又显得，他那么谦逊和低调。如此谦逊。我太喜欢他了。
It's real. And it's all so real. He doesn't need any attention. He's almost shy. Yet he's in a public, public role. Yeah. I find that admirable and interesting. I didn't even get to the thing that I said in his,
这都是真的。而且一切都是那么真实。他不需要任何关注。他甚至有点害羞。但他却身处一个公开的、公众的角色中。对。我觉得这既令人钦佩又有趣。我甚至都没聊到我在他，
in his intro, which was he, I wanted to ask him, the whole point of my intro was to ask him about, he starred in Paula Abdul's music video, Rush Rush in the nineties. And I was like, why is Keanu Reeves in this video? It was so wild. I remember it was like a big deal because I was obsessed with that video. Maybe he was dating her at the time.
在他的开场白里说的那件事，也就是他——我想问他，我开场白的核心就是要问他，他在 90 年代主演了宝拉·阿巴杜的音乐录影带《Rush Rush》。我当时就想：为什么基努·里维斯会出现在这个 MV 里？这太离谱了。我记得这当时是个大新闻，因为我迷恋那个 MV 不行。也许他当时在跟她交往。
That's what I wanted to ask. Well, he's not, he's way, no, no, no, he's way too discreet. He never would have said it. Call him back, Sean. Okay. This is the first time we ever want to get, we want to get a guest back. We didn't get to a lot of stuff because there's so much to talk to,
这就是我想问的。好吧，他没有，他太，不，不，不，他太谨慎了。他绝对不会说的。回给他打个电话，肖恩。好吧。这是我们第一次这么想把一个嘉宾再请回来。我们有很多事都没聊到，因为有太多话题可以跟他，
talk to him about. I know. I want to talk to him more about the matrix stuff, but anyway. I mean, you did a terrible job asking questions. If I'm being honest. Yeah. You're going to lose your nomination next year. You are.
跟他聊了。我知道。我还想跟他多聊聊《黑客帝国》的事，不过算了。我是说，你提问的表现简直糟糕透了。如果实话实说的话。对。你明年的提名要泡汤了。真的。
Oh, you've already, you've already a lot. You're never getting back to host of the year. Well, I can probably see that award go. Bye. Bye. You're just using a bye for bye, huh? That's right. Okay.
哦，你已经，你已经有很多了。你永远也拿不回年度主持人的奖了。好吧，我大概能看着那个奖飞走了。拜拜。你直接用一个“拜”来结束对话啊？没错。好吧。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. smart. Smart, this is 100% organic in our tisently handcrafted by Rob. Armjolf, Bennett, Barbeque, and Michael Gran Terri.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明，这是 100% 有机的，由罗布精心手工制作。阿姆乔尔夫·本内特、巴贝克和迈克尔·格兰特里。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Hi, so listener, before we go, we wanted to introduce the audience to someone very special today. Please meet someone special. SmartList Media is doing our very first podcast called Bad Dates with the amazing, incredible Jamila Jamil. Hi. Welcome. Jamila Jamil.
嗨，听众朋友们，在我们离开之前，今天我们要向大家介绍一位非常特别的人。请见识一下这位特别嘉宾。SmartList Media 正在制作我们的首档播客，名为《糟糕的约会》，由惊艳、不可思议的贾米拉·贾米尔主持。嗨。欢迎。贾米拉·贾米尔。
Do I clap myself? Yes. Clap yourself. Enthusiastic. Thank you. You can give yourself the clap. Yeah, yeah. If you're thinking of giving yourself the clap, this is called Bad Dates, right?
我是该给自己鼓掌吗？是的。给自己鼓掌。热情点。谢谢。你可以给自己鼓掌。对，对。如果你在考虑给自己鼓掌，这个节目叫做《糟糕的约会》，对吧？
Right. Unbelievable segue. Yeah. The show is called Bad Dates, yeah. Yeah, and are you, well, tell the listener basically what it's about beyond what the title says. It is relatively self-explanatory. It's just me and some of my favorite comedians and people coming on to disclose the sordid
对。不可思议的转折。对。这个节目叫《糟糕的约会》，对吧？对，而且你——好吧，除了标题之外，跟听众大致讲讲这节目是关于什么的。这其实不言自明。就是我和一些我最喜欢的喜剧演员和嘉宾一起来揭露他们经历过的那些最傻、最怪、最恶心的约会的肮脏
details of the silliest and weirdest and grossest dates they've ever had. And the reason I love this subject is because it's very bonding. It never fails to ignite a conversation wherever you are. It brings like barriers down, but also there's just a democracy to it because it just doesn't matter how hot you are, how smart, how rich, how famous, no one is exempt from a shitty fucking date. Right. But I would guess that you have never had a bad date because you seem to know how to
细节。我热爱这个主题的原因是它非常有凝聚力。无论你在哪里，它总能瞬间点燃对话。它能打破隔阂，而且它有一种平民属性，因为无论你有多性感、多聪明、多富有、多有名，没有任何人能免于经历一场糟糕透顶的约会。对。不过我猜你一定没经历过糟糕的约会，因为你似乎知道如何在任何可能的情况下进行沟通来让事情顺利进行，比如你能回答问题，也能提出问题，而有些人只会做其中一样。当我……我不是要说被唤醒，但当我感兴趣时，我所有的社交技能都会飞到九霄云外，真的就像我完全接收不到任何社交暗示。所以实际上你必须钻进我身体里，我才能明白你对我有兴趣。哦，鉴于当前的气候，这可不太合适。但你的意思是，如果你喜欢对方，你就会开始有点不知所措。
communicate in any way possible to make it all work, like you can answer the questions or you can ask the questions, like some people just don't only know how to do one. It comes to a standstill when I am, I'm not going to say aroused, but when I'm interested, all of my skills fly out the window and really like I have no way of receiving a sort of social cue. So really you have to be inside of me for me to understand that you're interested. Oh, given the current climate, that's not appropriate. But you're saying if you like the other person, you start to lock up a little bit.
我完全会。我会不知所措然后闭口不谈。对。威尔对查理兹·塞隆就是这样。他根本。你不需要，你没必要把范围扩大到那。她知道的。别担心。
I complete. I lock up and I shut down. Yeah. Will's got that with Charlize Theron. He can't. You don't need to, you don't need to go wide with that. She knows. Don't worry.
她心里有数。没事的。好吧，我们对查理兹都有这种感觉。有。你在《糟糕的约会》里有最喜欢的嘉宾吗？我是说，有谁浮现在脑海里吗？你可能在暗示谁？我不知道。肖恩，你一直是节目里非常棒的嘉宾。
She's aware. It's fine. Well, we all have that with Charlize. There are. Have you had a favorite guest yet on bad dates at all? I mean, anybody in come to mind, who could you be hinting at? I don't know. Sean, you've been a wonderful guest on the show.
好吧，给我们，给我们，给我们透露点内幕，肖恩。你的第一次约会是怎么样的？我不想剧透，但故事开头是我在一个酒吧里和一个穿着健身裤的家伙见面。我们俩都超级醉。我们回到了他的住处，然后在我们进行到故事的精彩部分之前，他问：“我可以……你介意我快速用微波炉热个墨西哥卷饼吗，因为我们马上就要大战一场了？”就是在这个时候发生的事情。
Well, give us, give us, give us a taste, Sean. What was your first date? I don't want to ruin it, but it starts out with me meeting a guy in a bar with workout pants in a bar. And we're both super drunk. We go back to his place and he, before we get to the goods part of the story, he asks, can I, do you mind if I microwave a burrito really quick because we go at it? That's where it got.
这不是委婉说法。不是委婉说法。如果你说的是“在我们继续聊天之前，你介意我先冲个澡吗？”我会更喜欢的。对，这是一场真正的梦幻体验，肖恩和柯南·奥布莱恩一起上了节目。我们还请过蒂格·诺塔罗。我们请过妮基·格拉瑟。等等，等等，等等，等等。柯南约过会？
Not a euphemism. Not a euphemism. I would have loved it if you said, you cool if I shower real quick before we keep talking? Yeah, it was, it was a real dream, Sean was on with Conan O'Brien. We've had Tig Notaro. We've had Nikki Glaser. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Conan's been on a date?
我知道。就那么一次。那是最……对。而且谢天谢地，那是一场灾难。所以他来节目里聊了这件事，但是——我了解到的关于许多名人的事情之多，真的相当惊人，还有就是有多少人在约会上拉过裤子。我不知道你们当中有没有人真的拉过裤子。
I know. Just the one. That's the most, yeah. And it was a disaster, thankfully. So he came on the show to talk about it, but it is just like, it is quite astonishing how much I've learned about a lot of very famous people and also just how many people have shit their pants on a date. I don't know if that's anything that any of you have, have literally shit their pants.
绝不可能。这其实就像，它是终极的平衡器。肛门是人类伟大的平衡器。我觉得它在政治上被忽视了，但我们在节目中把它发掘出来了。太迷人了。我真想听听这方面的全部内容。我一定要收听。哦，顺便说一句，你刚才成功引起了杰森的注意。
No way. It's actually like, it is, it is the great equalizer. The asshole is the great equalizer of humanity. And I think it's been overlooked politically, but we've uncovered it on the show. Fascinating. I want to hear all about that. I am tuning in. Oh, by the way, you just got Jason's attention.
约会和滚床单，行吧，没关系，这挺好。但一旦你进入了——简短的总结。肛门。对。肛门。故事的核心。大本营。
The dates and the hooking up, fine, no, it's fine. But once you get into the- Short wrap. The anus. Yeah. The anus. The wheels of the story. The wheelhouse.
约会和上床，行吧，不，这没什么。但一旦你进入了——简短的总结。肛门。是的。肛门。故事的核心。专长。
Sean, am I right? Yeah. Could you call the show shit show? I basically should. But I mean, there are varieties on what we're learning on the show, but it is just, I just want people out there to know that you are, you are not alone if you think you are. Like the stories are so wild and so funny and so absurd. And we're not shitting on single life because God knows married life is fucking its own nightmare.
肖恩，我说的对吗？是的。你难道不应该把这个节目叫“狗屎秀”吗？我基本上应该这么叫。但我的意思是，我们在节目中了解到的内容形形色色，我只是想让大家知道，如果你觉得自己很孤单，其实你并不孤单。那些故事太疯狂、太有趣、太荒谬了。我们并不是在贬低单身生活，因为天知道已婚生活本身就是一场该死的噩梦。
But we're just trying to like have an intimate, funny conversation about something that I think is deeply relatable. My story amazingly didn't involve any shit, but I've had my own like extraordinary disaster. Sean, I've told you the story before, but I can share it with you if you want an idea. Please do. Yeah. Of how much disaster is out there. I am, I tried to have my first ever one night stand because I've, I've only kissed
但我们只是想就一件我认为极其引起共鸣的事情进行一次亲密、有趣的对话。我的故事神奇地没有涉及任何狗屎，但我也有过自己那种非同寻常的灾难。肖恩，我以前给你讲过这个故事，但如果你想了解一下的话，我可以跟你分享。请讲吧。是的。看看外面有多少灾难。我，我试着经历我的第一次一夜情，因为我，我只亲过
six people, right? Come on. In my life. But it is sadly true. I started very late and then I, I was slow on the uptake. And so I, I thought, you know what, in my thirties, I'm going to have my her era that I've always dreamed of. It's going to happen.
六个人，对吧？拜托。我这一生中。但这确实是悲哀的真理。我开始得很晚，而且我，我开窍很慢。所以，我，我心想，你知道吗，在我三十多岁的时候，我要经历我一直梦想的那个属于我的时代。这一定会发生的。
And I, I, I, I got the sense that I was about to have my first ever booty call, a man that I'd been sort of casually going on a few dates with just hanging out with, we hadn't done anything yet. He texted me and said, do you want, like, shall I come over and I was like, oh, 11pm. I'm definitely going to get my first, so you can even hear what's happening to my voice just talking about it. I suddenly become like a bit more like Mary Poppins about the whole thing. But I was like, oh my God, I'm going to get a casual shag.
而且我，我，我，我感觉我马上就要有生以来第一次约炮了，一个我一直在随便约会、偶尔见几次面、一起闲逛的男人，我们当时还没发生过什么。他发短信给我说，你想，我过去好吗？我说，哦，晚上11点。我绝对能迎来我的第一次，所以你甚至能从我谈论它时的声音中听到发生了什么。谈到这事时，我突然变得有点像玛丽·波平斯。但我想，哦天哪，我要去和人随便滚床单了。
It's so exciting. So he, he turns up at my house, 11pm on the door, walks into my apartment. I've only been living in America for a week at this point, right? So I don't know anyone or anything. And he takes three steps in and collapses face first on the ground. And all of his front teeth, we're talking at least 12 here. Out of his mouth, across my entire living room. So now there is blood and teeth all over my room and he's having a seizure.
太令人兴奋了。所以他，他出现在我家，晚上11点敲门，走进我的公寓。此时我搬到美国才一个星期，对吧？所以我谁也不认识，什么都不知道。他刚走三步，就脸朝下瘫倒在地上。他所有的门牙，我们这里说的是至少12颗。从他嘴里飞出来，散落在我整个客厅里。所以现在我的房间到处都是血和牙齿，而且他正在癫痫发作。
So I've never seen someone have a seizure in real life before and I panic. I think he's going to die. I call 911, which is also slightly exciting because, you know, I'm English and they call that in the movies. So I feel very Hollywood right now, I call 911. They send in the fucking police to turn up the fire brigade, the paramedics. Everyone comes rolling into my house. I now have about 25 men in my apartment, which is not how I'd expected my house to be.
所以我以前从未在现实生活中见过有人癫痫发作，我惊慌失措。我以为他要死了。我拨打了911，这也稍微有点让人兴奋，因为，你知道的，我是英国人，他们只在电影里打这个。所以我现在感觉自己非常的好莱坞，我打了911。他们派出了该死的警察，消防队，医护人员也赶到了。所有人都涌进我的房子，现在我的公寓里大约有25个男人，这和我预期的我的房子的情况完全不同。
And you're just in lingerie, right? You were ready to go. No, not quite, but close. And this man is covered in blood. He's, he's, he's split his chin all the way open and they're trying to resuscitate him. They managed to bring him to, and they're like, excuse me, sir. Like, you know, have you, have you taken anything? Do you have epilepsy?
而你当时正穿着内衣，对吧？你当时都准备好了。不，不太算，但差不多。这个男人浑身是血。他，他，他把下巴裂开了一个大口子，他们正在试图对其实施心肺复苏。他们设法让他醒了过来，他们问，打扰一下，先生。就像，你知道，你，你吃过什么东西吗？你有癫痫吗？
And he was like, oh, I might have had some cocaine, but he was like, but I always have cocaine. And I was like, oh, it's a small red flag. It's not a huge one. It's a little, it was just, I think the word always at his age felt slightly disturbing. Wasn't going to be a short date. No, exactly. And then they were like, have you taken anything else?
然后他说，哦，我可能吸了一些可卡因，但他又说，但我一直都在吸可卡因。我当时就想，哦，这是一个小红旗。算不上多大。这只是一个小问题，我觉得他这个年纪说“一直”这个词让人觉得有点不安。看来这不是一次短时间的约会。不，完全是这样。然后他们问，你还吸食了别的东西吗？
And he was going, no. And he's hiding in the street like this because he's got no teeth now. And so they start putting the blanket over him to take him out. And as they go past his cock, he gets a raging erection, which feels inappropriate in a moment. And they're like, sir, have you taken anything else? And he turns around and he looks directly at me and makes full eye contact and just goes, I might have had some Viagra, which is, I might have had some Viagra who don't speak toothless.
他回答说，没有。他像这样躲在街上，因为他现在没有牙齿了。于是他们开始把毯子盖在他身上准备把他抬出去。当他们经过他的命根子时，他竟然勃起了，这在当时的情况下显得很不合时宜。他们问，先生，你还吸食了别的东西吗？他转过身来，直勾勾地看着我，四目相对，然后说，我可能吃了一些伟哥。那是，说话漏风的人才会说我可能吃了一些伟哥。
So that's a combination you don't want. So then you hook up. So quickly sucked him off and sent him on his way. Yeah. He got carried out in on a stretcher in the middle of us Hollywood of quite famous actor. So we had to put a blanket over his cock, but also one over his face. And he's just, there's just like pitching a tent through West Hollywood as he gets taken to the hospital.
所以这是一个你绝对不想看到的组合。然后你们就勾搭上了。于是我飞快地帮他口交完，然后把他打发走了。是的。他躺在担架上被抬了出去，在西好莱坞正中间，就像一个相当著名的演员。所以我们不得不拿一条毯子盖住他的命根子，还得拿一条盖住他的脸。当他被抬往医院时，他就在西好莱坞支起了帐篷。
So that was, that was my first and last attempt at a boutique hall and have been in a long term relationship since a week from that day. Oh my God. I can't wait to get you drunk one day and find out who that guy was. I can't believe Thoreau has never told us this story. Right. He's literally open about his mistakes. Normally you'd think that he would.
所以那次，那是我第一次也是最后一次尝试约炮，从那天起的一周内我就开始了一段长期恋爱关系。天哪。我真想有一天灌醉你，查出那家伙到底是谁。我真不敢相信梭罗从来没给我们讲过这个故事。对吧。他平时对自己的失误直言不讳。通常你会觉得他会的。
So that is what can happen. I know. See, I live for those kinds of stories and you can see how everybody has one or two or five or 10 of these horrible stories. Ask her if she's ever forgotten a line on stage, you know, any weird theater stories. Hey, give me a really horrible theater story. That's just a dynamic. You have to tune into smart list for that one.
所以这就是可能发生的事情。我知道。你看，我就是为了听这种故事而活的，你能看出每个人都有这一类一两个、五个或十个可怕的故事。问问她是否曾在舞台上忘词，你知道的，有没有什么奇怪的戏剧故事。嘿，给我讲一个真正可怕的戏剧故事。这就是一种动态。为此你得收听“聪明名单”。
But for all bad date stories, tune in. Yes. Bad dates. When do we get to start airing these things? So March 28th, it'll be on Wondery Plus and Amazon Music. And then March 27th, it'll be on all services. And you can just sit back, relax, and enjoy the truly horrible tales of some people's dating experiences.
但对于所有糟糕的约会故事，敬请收听。是的。糟糕的约会。我们什么时候开始播出这些节目？3月28日，它将在Wondery Plus和Amazon Music上线。然后3月27日，它将在所有服务上线。你可以坐下来，放松身心，享受某些人那些真正糟糕的约会经历的故事。
It's just amazing what we'll go through to get a shag, isn't it? Yeah. That's true. Boy, that's a quote. Well, we're lucky, Jamila, that we have you taking us through this. Yeah. It's going to be so great. We're really excited for it.
为了和人滚床单，我们居然愿意经历这些，真是太神奇了，不是吗？是的。确实如此。天哪，这真是一句名言。詹米拉，我们有你带我们经历这一切，真是太幸运了。是的。这将会非常棒。我们对此真的非常兴奋。
You're our first one. You're our virgin podcast. Yeah, you're our first one. Thank you. No pressure at all. No pressure. Yeah. Yeah.
你是我们的第一个嘉宾。你是我们的处女秀播客。是的，你是我们的第一个。谢谢。毫无压力。毫无压力。是的。是的。
Thanks. I'm a massive fan of all of you. I don't know if I can, because this podcast is so weird and gross that I think it's going to fly. Well, thank you, our big fans. Thank you for doing this, and we can't wait to listen. Likewise. Thank you.
谢谢。我是你们所有人的超级粉丝。我不知道我能不能行，因为这个播客太怪异、太恶心了，我觉得它一定会火。好吧，谢谢你，我们的超级粉丝。谢谢你来参加，我们已经迫不及待想要收听了。彼此彼此。谢谢。
Thank you, Han. Bye, Jamila. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Last.
谢谢汉。再见，詹米拉。再见。再见。再见。再见。聪明。名单。
Smart. Last. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。名单。再见。再见。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。